SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEDINA RESIDENT MEDINA PRESENT
CHOI CHOI PRESENT ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA PRESENT BERMAN BLOOM.
BLAME PRESENT GABRIEL IRWIN
KILEY LEVINE LEVINE PRESENT LOW
LOW PRESENT SANTIAGO BALLADARES
BUT THERE IS PRESENT. WE HAVE
SEVEN MEMBERS PRESENT WE HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU. WELCOME TO
THE FIRST BILL HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WHETHER YOU ARE HERE
IN PERSON. WATCHING VIRTUALLY
OR ON THE PHONE LINES I AM
GRATEFUL YOU HAVE JOINED US
HERE ON THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER FLOOR. PLEASE
NOTE THE FOLLOWING FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN A. B. TWO NINE NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARLOS VIA
BUDDHA HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S HEARING AND IS NOW A TO
YOUR BILL. I APPRECIATE THE
MEMBER AND HIS WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE. OVER
THE ENTRANCE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARC BERMAN HAS BEEN APPOINTED
BY THE SPEAKER TO REPLACE THE
VACANCY FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN AND WELCOME TO TODAY'S
HIGHER EDUCATION HEARING. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO EXTEND A
WARM ASSEMBLY. READING AND
WELCOME TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
SET BY A THAT IS THE NEWEST
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY'S
OUR FIRST POLICY HEARING WITH
THIS. WELCOME. I WILL NOW GO
OVER SOME OF THE KEY ELEMENTS
OF THE STRUCTURE OF TODAY'S
HEARING. DUE TO THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. IN THIS
HEARING AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING AND PERSON. WE
HAVE DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR
THOSE PRESENT ON THE CHAMBER
FLOOR AND IN THE GALLERY WE ARE
HAVING A PHYSICAL PHYSICALLY
DISTANT IN PERSON HEARING. IN
THIS SPACE WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AUTHORS AND A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX
FEET OF SPACING. THEY'RE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE TODAY IN A
HEARING. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND I WILL ASK YOU
TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD
ASK THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARINGS ONCE YOU FINISH
TESTIFYING. OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BY LEAVING
THE CAPITAL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USE TO ONE PERSON AT A
TIME. IN ADDITION TO BEING ABLE
TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF OUR
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS THAT ARE LOCATED HERE IN
THE CAPITAL. THOSE WITNESSES
WILL APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO
MEMBERS CAN WATCH THEIR
TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE OF
THE HEARING ROOM. AND ALSO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THESE WITNESSES.
THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT DELAY FOR
THE STREAM FROM THE WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM SO
PLEASE BE PATIENT. WE WILLALSO
BE USING EIGHTEEN T. MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT
DELAY THERE AS WELL SO AGAIN I
ASK THAT ALL INVOLVED PLEASED
TO REMAIN PATIENT. THE PUBLIC
TOLL FREE CALLING NUMBER FOR
THE HEARING. IS ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS TWO FOUR TWO. SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THE
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WEBSITE. A.
H. E. D. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT C. A.
DOT G. O. V. AS WELL AS ON YOUR
TV OR MONITOR SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHORED THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE. THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVE STREAM BROADCASTS AND
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE BE
SURE TO MUTE YOUR PHONE WHEN
YOU ARE NOT SPEAKING. PLEASE
ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF YOUR
LEAD WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST THE
BILL YOU WILL REMAIN ON A
LIFELINE AND WILL NEED TO MUTE
YOURSELF. UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED
ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH MODERATOR
PHONE SERVICE PLEASE CALL THE
COMMITTEE OFFICE. AT NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE. THREE NINE
SIX ZERO AND COMMITTEE STAFF
WILL DO THEIR BEST TO ASSIST
YOU. PLEASE NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE PORTION. THROUGH
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
ADDITIONALLY PLEASE NOTE THAT
THE GUIDELINE FOR BILLS HEARD
IN THIS COMMITTEE IS TO ALLOW
TESTIMONY FROM TO LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND TO
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
SPEAK FOR NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES EACH. STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS AND ENTITIES THAT ARE
NEITHER IN SUPPORT NOR IN
OPPOSITION WILL BE ALLOWED TO
GIVE TESTIMONY FOR NO MORE THAN
TWO MINUTES WHEN I CALL FOR
TWEETERS. THE MEASURE HAS MORE
THAN TWO ENTITIES AND THE
TWEENER CATEGORY ONLY TWO WILL
BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK. FOR TWO
MINUTES EACH. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
RESPOND TO A ROLL CALL. ASK A
QUESTION OR PROVIDE A COMMENT.
YOU WILL NEED TO RAISE YOUR
MATT MICROPHONES OF STAFF CAN
ACTIVATED WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AS BE. ALSO PLEASE
STAND UP AND FACE THE
MICROPHONE WHILE SPEAKING. TO
ENSURE YOUR VOICE IS AUDIBLE
AND COULD BE RECORDED. FOR
AUTHORS OF BILLS UP TODAY. EACH
MEMBER PRESENTED TODAY WILL
PROVIDE AN OPENING AND CLOSING
STATEMENT YOUR TO LEAD
WITNESSES WILL BE ANNOUNCED BY
THE CHAIR. AND I AS I
PREVIOUSLY STATED WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
THE FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
THE ADOPTION OF THE COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE RULES. IS THERE A
MOTION FOR ADOPTION OF THE
COMMITTEE RULES. THANK YOU I
HAVE- THE FIRST. BY MISS. WHY
IT ARTIST AND A SECOND. BUT MR
BLUE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I ARAMBULA. BERMAN BLOOM.
BLOOM HI GABRIEL. IRWIN KILEY.
LEVINE LEVINE I LOW. SANTIAGO
THE ISLANDERS. BALLADARES HI.
VOTES FIVE ZERO WE- NEED TO
MORE. SO WE WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN. YEAH AND PER SE OKAY
THANK YOU. SO BEFORE WE PROCEED
TO BILLS WE WILL TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE HAVE FIVE
BILLS ON CONSENT. WE HAVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FILE ITEM SIX
AB ONE OH TWO. AS AMENDED. FILE
ITEM SEVEN A. B. NINE ONE FOUR.
FILE ITEM TEN A. B. FOUR ONE
SEVEN. FILE ITEM TWELVE A. B.
THREE THREE SEVEN FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN A. B. THREE FOUR ZERO.
HAVE A FIRST BY MISTER CHOI ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND A
SECOND BY MR LEVINE OF MADAM
SECRETARY BE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI
CHOI I ARAMBULA. BERMAN BLOOM
BLOOM HI GABRIEL IRWIN KILEY
LEVINE. LEVINE I LOW SANTIAGO
VALIDUS VALIDUS HI. THE VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO. RIGHT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS PASSED WE WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH
THE FIRST BILL- NOT SEEN ANYONE
HERE FOR- MR BONTA- WE'LL GO TO
THE SECOND ITEM A. B. THREE
NINE- THEY ARE THEY WILL GO
AHEAD AND PROCEED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SELFISH LAW LIKE TO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR WORK
WITH MY STAFF OUT PARTICULARLY
OVER THE LAST TWO WEEKS. I WANT
TO START BY ACCEPTING ALL OF
THE AMENDMENTS LISTED ON PAGE
THREE OF THE COMEDIAN ALICE
ANALYSIS TO ONE AUTHORIZED
INSTEAD OF MANDATE THE UC
REGENTS TO ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA CHINA CLIMATE IS TO.
TO REMOVE REFERENCES TO A
SPECIFIC CAMPUS LOCATION FOR
THE INSTITUTE AND THREE TO
CLARIFY THAT THE INSTITUTE WILL
TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE RECEIVE
GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT FROM
POLICY EXPERTS GOVERNMENT
BUSINESS ACADEMIC AND CLIMATE
LEADERS AND ADVISORY
COMMITTEES. AB THIRTY NINE
WOULD CODIFY AND RECOGNIZED THE
CALIFORNIA CHINA CLIMATE
INSTITUTE TO ACCELERATE CLIMATE
ACTION THROUGH COOPERATIVE
EFFORTS AND EXCHANGES BETWEEN
TWO OF THE WORLD'S LARGEST
ECONOMIC POWERS. AND MAJOR
EMITTERS OF GREENHOUSE GASES
CALIFORNIA AND CHINA. THERE ARE
MANY SERIOUS THREATS WE FACE
THAT AREN'T CONSTRAINED BY
NATIONAL BORDERS AND AFFECT
EVERYONE AROUND THE WORLD. TO
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
MAKE THAT CLEAR. THE CLIMATE
CHANGE CRISIS IS NO DIFFERENT.
TO ADDRESS THE CLIMATE CRISIS
AND REDUCE EMISSIONS WE MUST
HAVE STRONG PARTNERSHIPS AROUND
THE WORLD. IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN FORMER CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR EDMUND G. BROWN JUNIOR
HELPED LAUNCH THE CALIFORNIA
CHINA CLIMATE INSTITUTE TO
PROMOTE CLIMATE ACTION THROUGH
JOINT RESEARCH TRAINING AND
DIALOGUE BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND
CHINA. THE INSTITUTE IS
PARTNERING WITH LEADING
ACADEMIC AND GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITIES IN CHINA AND PROVIDING
A PLATFORM TO BUILD THESE
URGENTLY NEEDED PARTNERSHIPS.
THE INSTITUTE ADVANCES JOINT
POLICY RESEARCH ON MAJOR
CLIMATE ISSUES INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO. LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION AND ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES CARBON
PRICING CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCE SUSTAINABLE LAND USE
AND CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE.
CARBON CAPTURE AND ALSO STORAGE
LONG TERM CLIMATE GOAL SETTING
AND POLICY ENFORCEMENT. BY
PASSING AB THIRTY NINE AND
FORMALIZING THE INSTITUTE IN
STATE LAW THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIST SENATE STRONG MESSAGE
THAT CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE
TO LEAD THE WAY TO REVERSE
CLIMATE CHANGE BY ADVANCING
JOINT CLIMATE RESEARCH. THROUGH
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
INSTITUTE AND CHINESE AND
AMERICAN OFFICIALS. TODAY I'M
HONORED TO HELP OUR FORMER
GOVERNOR EDMUND G. BROWN JUNIOR
AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT. AT&T MODERATOR WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE FIRST LEAD
WITNESS WAS CALLING IN FOR A BI
THIRTY NINE. GOVERNOR ED MEN G.
BROWN JUNIOR. GOVERNOR BROWN
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND-
MY GREETINGS TO ALL MY FRIENDS
AND THOSE WHO I HAVEN'T QUITE
MET YET- I MISSILE YOU GUYS
IT'S A LITTLE QUIET AND END UP
MEN AND WOMEN- WERE APPEARING
IN THAT WEST COLUSA COUNTY WITH
MOSTLY CAL. AND A LOT OF TREES
SO IT'S A LITTLE QUIETER IN THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR ANYWAY I'M GOING
TO SPEAK FOR A MINUTE OR TWO
ABOUT THIS BILL- WE SET UP THE
INSTITUTE TWENTY NINETEEN TO
FURTHER THE- COOPERATION THAT
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD HAD- WITH CHINESE
REGULATORS- CLIMATE CHANGE AS
YOU KNOW IS THE- EXISTENTIAL
THREAT. IF THE TEMPERATURE IS
RISING CALIFORNIA IS KNOWN AS
DROUGHT ONE OF THE DRIEST YEARS
ON RECORD OF COURSE FOR IS A
TERRIBLE LAST YEAR THEY MAY BE
JUST AS BAD THIS YEAR WE HAVE
TO DO SOMETHING THE MAJOR
EMITTER IN THE WORLD IS CHINA
27% OF THE GREENHOUSE GAS
NUMBER TWO IS THE UNITED STATES
THAT THIRTEEN PERCENT. SO WE'RE
40% OF THE PROBLEMS WE HAVE TO
BE AT LEAST 40% OF THE SOLUTION
I KNOW. THERE ARE DEEP AND
PROFOUND PROBLEMS THAT THE IN
CHINA AS WELL TO SPEAK OUT AND
DEAL WITH THESE BUT WE HAVE TO
OUT- ISSUES IS THE PROBLEM
COURSE IS NOT GOING AWAY- WE'RE
GONNA HIT- ONE POINT 5%
CENTIGRADE IN. AND TEMPLATE-
BUT- TWO IF WE DON'T DO REALLY
TRASH WE CAN'T WAIT THIS IS
URGENT- THERE'S A TWO IS A VERY
IN- OPPORTUNE TO. ON THE SIDE
AND RE BASIS IT ALSO FOSTERING
DIALOGUE ALREADY HAD ONE WITH
JOHN KERRY- THE- CHINESE
AMBASSADOR TO PARIS- CLIMATE
CONFERENCE- MINISTRY SHIA XIN
WHILE- BUNKY MOON- IT AND
OTHERS. WHO WERE WORKING TO
DEAL WITH ONE TOPIC THE
COMMISSION. OF HEAT TRAPPING.
AND WE'RE DO THAT- WITH FOCUS
ON ZERO HERE. BUILDING
REGULATIONS A REGULATE- AND- A
CARBON PRICE. AND NATCHER AND
CAP. THESE ARE ALL. GIVEN
TOPICS IT DIFFICULT FOR
CALIFORNIA FOR AMERICA FOR
CHINA AND FOR THE WORLD WE NEED
TO WORK TOGETHER THE TIME- IT
IS VERY SHORT. AND SO I HOPE
THAT YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
ENTHUSIASTICALLY JOINED IN
THIS. EFFORT THAT ALREADY HAS
BEEN PRODUCING SOME RESULTS
WE'RE GONNA TRAINING PEOPLE- IN
IN CREDIT RELATED- TASK AND
THAT'S WERE INTO WE'RE NOT INTO
POLITICS WE'RE GOING TO THE
OTHER ISSUE THE REDUCING HEAT
TRAPPING GASES. AND CALIFORNIA
IS ONE OF THE HOT SPOT WE'RE
GOING TO BE SUFFERING GREATLY
IF WE CAN'T MAKE A MAJOR.
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE AT HOME AND
ABROAD AND WITHOUT CHINA IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE U. S.
THERE'S NO WAY TO GET THERE SO
I. WOULD ASK FOR IT AND I VOTE.
THEY YOU GOVERNOR BROWN ALWAYS
GOOD TO HEAR FROM YOU. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER IN
THE GALLERY. NOT SEEN ANY ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER- IN THE
GALLERY. I'D SEEN IN OTHER
THERE AS WELL. ANY TRAINERS IN
THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER IN THE
GALLERY. DON'T SEE ANY THERE SO
NOW MOVING TO THE PHONE LINES.
AT&T MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE. EIGHTEEN
T. MODERATOR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
BUT FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO.
PLEASE BE SURE TO MEET YOUR
CHAIR WE HAVE AT LEAST. GO
AHEAD WE HAVE AT LEAST- WHAT.
WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE
PARTICIPANT THAT WISHES TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLACE.
WE
WILL NOW GO TO LINE TWENTY
THREE LINE TWENTY THREE OH ONE
SO BUT- YOUR NUMBER THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
ONE OF THE SUPPORT AB THIRTY
NINE AND WE WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF FORMER GOVERNOR
BROWN MANY TO THE VOTED BALLOTS
WITH ANY TICKET SEVENTY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT-
MODERATOR. HAVE YOU CHAIR NO
ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT ALL
RIGHT THEN I WILL GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE. FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR
NO ONE IS SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MODERATOR. ANY ANY
TWEETERS ON THE PHONE. MISTER
MODERATOR. AND AGAIN ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR NO ONE IS SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. MR LEVINE. OUR
SYSTEM YEAH I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU AS
WELL ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO FOR-
FOR OFFERING THIS LEGISLATION-
THANK YOU ALSO TO GOVERNOR
BROWN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THE
CLIMATE CRISIS- WE ARE IN A
MUCH BETTER POSITION GLOBALLY
BECAUSE OF GOVERNOR BROWN'S
LEADERSHIP AND THE SUBNATIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS AND REGIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS THAT GOVERNOR
BROWN FOR JUST AS AS GOVERNOR.
OF CALIFORNIA. WE LIKE TO THINK
OF OURSELVES RIGHTLY SO AS A MY
ID ECONOMIC POWER BUT ALSO. A
MIGHTY VALUES DRIVEN POWER. AND
SO WHILE I ONE OF MY FONDEST
MEMORIES ARE OF GOVERNOR BROWN
IS AN INTERACTION WITH THAT
WITH MY WIFE AND ME WHEN MY
WIFE ASKED HIM WHAT HE WAS
GOING TO DO IN RETIREMENT HE
SAID WELL I'M GOING TO SOLVE
THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND- TAKE ON
YOU KNOW NUCLEAR WAR- AND JUST
OKAY THAT SOUNDS LIKE A BUSY
RETIREMENT SO- A LOT OF RESPECT
FOR. EIGHTY NOT I WOULD EVEN
DESCRIBE IT AS A SECOND CAREER.
JUST A VERY- ANOTHER CAREER. IN
A LONG LINE OF TACKLING SOME OF
OUR BIGGEST PROBLEMS AND THE
CLIMATE CRISIS IS. AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT PROBABLY THE
GREATEST THREAT. THAT HUMANITY
HAS EVER FACED- ON ON PAR WITH
NUCLEAR ANNIHILATION. AND AND
I'M GRATEFUL THAT- THAT BROWN
IS PUTTING HIS ENERGIES TOWARD
THAT AND THAT YOU SEE. IS ABLE
TO CONTINUE- PARTNERING WITH
THOSE WHO CAN DO THE VERY MOST.
TO LIMIT THE THREAT. OF THE OF
THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND THAT.
ABSOLUTELY MUST INCLUDE CHINA.
IF WE'RE NOT LOOKING TOWARD
CHINA AS A PLACE FOR SOLUTIONS
TO OUR BIGGEST PROBLEMS WE
WOULD BE LOOKING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION CHINA MUST BE A PART
OF THE SOLUTION- IN CHINA AS AN
AMAZING PLACE AN AMAZING
CULTURE. AN AMAZING ECONOMIC
POWER- NYTHING PEOPLE PLACE
I'VE BEEN PRIVILEGED TO VISIT.
MY CHILDREN STUDY MANDARIN IN
SCHOOL I FIRMLY BELIEVE CHINA
IS PART OF CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE.
AND SO. I KNOW THAT THIS
CLIMATE WORKING CONTINUE
WITHOUT THIS LEGISLATION. AND
AND I STRUGGLE WITH THIS
LEGISLATION NOT BECAUSE OF THE
THREAT THAT THE CLIMATE CRISIS-
CONFRONTS US WITH. BUT BECAUSE
OF OTHER ISSUES HAPPENING
INSIDE CHINA'S BORDERS RIGHT
NOW. THAT CANNOT GO UNNOTICED
THAT WE KNOW ABOUT. THAT WE ARE
ALL AWARE OF THAT SECRETARY OF
STATE TONY BLINKEN REFERRED TO
AS GENOCIDE JUST THIS WEEK- IN
REFERENCE TO CHINA'S TREATMENTS
OF THE UIGHUR MUSLIMS. SO WE
CAN'T JUST ACT LIKE EVERYTHING
IS NORMAL WHEN WE ARE ENGAGING
WITH CHINA EVEN ON EXISTENTIAL
THREATS. WHEN WE KNOW. THAT
REALLY BAD THINGS ARE HAPPENING
INSIDE CHINA. AND I THINK ABOUT
WHAT WOULD OCCUR DURING A
DIFFERENT VERY CHALLENGING TIME
FOR ALL THE PEOPLE ON OUR
PLANET. DURING THE GLOBAL
DEPRESSION DURING THE GREAT
DEPRESSION OF THE THIRTIES. IF
CALIFORNIA OR THE UNITED STATES
OR OTHER. ANOTHER MIGHTY
ECONOMIC POWER THOUGHT. GERMANY
IS THE LINCHPIN OF GETTING
HUMANITY OUT OF THIS ECONOMIC
CRISIS. IMAGINE THIS BEING POST
KRISTALLNACHT MAYBE PRE DEATH
COUNT TERMINATE. AND WE SAID WE
CAN PULL THE WHOLE GLOBE OUT OF
THIS. SO LET'S HAVE STRONGER
PARTNERSHIPS WITH GERMANY. WELL
WE KNEW THAT INTERMENT CAMPS
CONCENTRATION CAMPS WERE GOING
ON. WHICH THEY PROBABLY DID.
BUT PEOPLE WENT ALONG. AND NO
ONE IN A DISTANT CAPITAL-
THOUGHT THAT THEY WERE MIGHTY
ARE POWERFUL. NEVER RECONCILED
THAT THIS IS GOING ON INSIDE
THAT COUNTRY INSIDE GERMANY
IMAGINE WHAT THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN LIKE. IT PROBABLY HAPPENED.
SO HERE WE ARE A CENTURY LATER.
AND WE KNOW WHAT IS HAPPENING.
WE HERE IN SACRAMENTO. THE
FIFTH MIGHTIEST ECONOMIC POWER
IN THE WORLD WE LIKE TO CALL
OURSELVES KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE TORN FROM
THEIR HOMES THEIR FAMILIES
THEIR LANGUAGE THEIR CULTURE
THEIR FAITH. PLACED IN CAMPS.
AND WE. ARE GOING TO ACT LIKE
IT'S BUSINESS AS USUAL. AND
CODIFY PARTNERSHIP THAT'S JUST
ALREADY TAKING PLACE ANYWAY.
WITHOUT RECOGNITION. THAT THIS
IS HAPPENING TO MILLIONS OF OUR
FELLOW MEMBERS OF HUMANITY. SO
IT'S NOT YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO AND
HOW WE RECONCILE THAT. AND HOW
WE PARTNER WITH CHINA. HELLO
PASSED BILLS AND LEGISLATION
THAT MAKE REFERENCE TO CHINA.
AND THIS IS A. AND IT'S
CHALLENGING BECAUSE I FULLY
RECOGNIZE THE EXISTENTIAL
THREAT THREAT THAT CLIMATE
CHANGES. IT'S NOT WORTH.
CASTING ASIDE. WHAT IS
HAPPENING TO A PART OF HUMANITY
IN CHINA WHEN WE DO THIS SO AS
THIS BILL IS FOR IT I DON'T I
DON'T BELIEVE I'M ABLE TO STOP
THIS BILL. AND I. TELL THE
AUTHOR THAT THAT WASN'T MY
INTENTION WHEN I. TOLD HIM I
NEEDED TO RAISE THESE ISSUES.
AB ALTHOUGH I DO NEED TO VOTE
NO. BUT THAT WE NEED TO
RECONCILE THIS AND HOW WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS LEGISLATION
AND HOW WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
HOW CALIFORNIA IF WE THINK THAT
WE ARE THE LEADERS OF THE WORLD
BOTH ECONOMICALLY AND VALUES
WISE. DEALS WITH THESE TYPES OF
ISSUES THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. MISTER JOY.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ARE- FOR
PRESENTING THIS- IMPORT ON.
CLIMB AT THE ISSUE I UNDERSTAND
A OF CALIFORNIA CHINA CLIMATE
THE INSTITUTE IS ALREADY IN
PLACE. AND- NOW THIS BILL IS-
TRYING TO- MANDATE. I WANT
THREE FOUR LEGISLATURE- OPTION
PLEASE SEND US SUCH A MANDATE
ON THE UC SYSTEM. AND THE FOR
THEM TO OUR PERMANENTLY HAVE A
SISTER INSTITUTION IN PLACE TO
AND THE DATA ONCE WE- REQUIRE
THEM- THE FUNDING WILL HAVE TO
FOLLOW- AND- ATOMIC FREEDOM MAY
BE INFRINGED I THAT SHOULD BE-
LEFT TO- THE UNIVERSITY- IS
OUT. HOW TO- I. THERE JUST ON.
INSTITUTE AND OF BASED UPON
THIS OFFER ON FORTY OUR.
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU FOR THE MISTER BLOOM. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR VICE
CHAIR- I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL- AND- I RESPECT VERY
MUCH THE COMMENTS- MADE BY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM THE NORTH SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA- BUT I
REACHED THE OPPOSITE CONCLUSION
WHILE HOLDING. UP VERY MUCH THE
SAME BELIEFS ABOUT THE BEHAVIOR
OF THE GOVERNMENT OF CHINESE-
THE OUTRAGEOUS AND DISGUSTING
BEHAVIOUR OF THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT WITH RESPECT TO THE
MUSLIM UIGHUR PEOPLE. WITHIN
ITS BORDERS- BUT IT'S NOT JUST
THAT. IT'S THE CRACKDOWN ON
DEMOCRACY IN HONG KONG THAT TO
CAUSES ME TO BE OUTRAGED IT'S
CHINESE INTERFERENCE IN OUR
ELECTIONS THAT CAUSES ME TO BE
OUTRAGED BUT IN SPITE OF ALL OF
THESE THINGS. THE EXISTENTIAL
THREAT OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
AND SO OVERRIDING THAT- I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO SUPPORT
THIS LEGISLATION AND THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR COLLABORATION
AND COOPERATION THAT FOLLOWS.
BY EXTENDING THESE BONDS
BETWEEN THE CHINESE PEOPLE AND
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AS
REPRESENTED THROUGH OUR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS WE ALSO
MAINTAIN IMPORTANT BONDS THAT
HOPEFULLY WILL UNDERMINE THESE
ANTI DEMOCRATIC. AND OTHER
OUTRAGES THAT WE SEE BEING
PERPETRATED BY THE GOVERNMENT.
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
EVERYONE'S I VOTE ON- ON THIS
BILL BECAUSE OUR CLIMATE CRISIS
IS EVERYTHING TO THE FUTURE OF
THIS COUNTRY TO CHINA TO EVERY
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD AND EVERY
PERSON WHO LIVES NOW. AND WILL
COME INTO THIS WORLD IN THE
FUTURE THAT'S HOW BROAD AND HOW
IMPORTANT THIS CRISIS AS. YEAH
WE HAVE A THE FIRST IS IT IS
OUR SECOND YEAH WELCOME TO GO
BACK TO MISTER RIGHT SO WE HAVE
A MOTION- MISTER GAVE A. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND COLLEAGUES I- I'VE WRESTLED
WITH SOME OF THE SAME ISSUES
AS- OUR COLLEAGUES FROM MARIN
COUNTY SANTA MONICA- ALSO
BELIEVE VERY FIRMLY THAT THE
CLIMATE CRISIS IS AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT THAT
MULTILATERAL DIALOGUE
PARTICULARLY WITH CHINA AS A
CENTRAL TO SOLVING THE CLIMATE
CRISIS THAT THAT THAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO BE PART OF
THAT DIALOGUE AND WE NEED TO
SUPPORT IT AND YOU KNOW I DON'T
THINK THAT THERE SHOULD BE AN
ISSUE HIGHER ON OUR PRIORITY
LIST THEN CLIMATE CHANGE IN
DEALING WITH WITH THE CHINESE
WITH THE REST OF THE WORLD. BUT
I ALSO WRESTLED WITH THE HUMAN
RIGHTS ISSUES THERE AND
PARTICULARLY THE ISSUE THE
UIGHURS- AND THAT'S SOMETHING I
WAS FORTUNATE OUR OUR GOVERNOR
FORMER GOVERNOR BROWN CALLED ME
LAST NIGHT WE SPOKE FOR ABOUT
THIRTY MINUTES ABOUT THIS AND
HAD A VERY- ROBUST CONVERSATION
WHICH I APPRECIATED VERY MUCH
AND WAS. WAS ULTIMATELY
PERSUADED THAT THERE ARE. OTHER
AVENUES IN WHICH WE CAN RAISE
THAT AND I THINK WE SHOULD I
THINK WE NEED TO AS A- OUR
COLLEAGUE SAID NEVER TAKE OUR
VALUES OFF THE TABLE. WE NEED
TO HAVE TOUGH CONVERSATIONS
INCLUDING WITH OUR ALLIES AND
FRIENDS. AND THE ISSUES OF
HUMAN RIGHTS ARE PARAMOUNT AND
I THINK WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO SPEAK TO THOSE PARTICULARLY.
WHEN THEY REACH A CERTAIN LEVEL
AND THE LEVEL THAT ARE- AND AS
WAS MENTIONED BY OUR COLLEAGUE
WHERE SECRETARY OF STATE. UNDER
SECRETARY STATUS DESCRIBE THIS
AS A GENOCIDE THAT IS NOT A
TERM THAT PEOPLE TAKE LIGHTLY.
THAT'S NOT A TERM THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF STATE
EMPLOYEES LIGHTLY. SO IT'S AN
IMPORTANT URGENT MATTER FOR US
TO ADDRESS. BUT AT THE SAME
TIME WE MUST ADDRESS THE
CLIMATE CRISIS THAT ISN'T
URGENT EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO
ALL HUMANITY SO I'M PERSUADED
TODAY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR-
FOR THE WORK IN AND FOR
STRENGTHENING THAT PARTNERSHIP
AND I I'VE ALWAYS BELIEVED THAT
IN DIPLOMACY YOU CAN HAVE.
CONVERSATIONS ON MULTIPLE
TRACKS AND YOU CAN WORK ON
AREAS WHERE YOU AGREE AND AREAS
WHERE YOU DISAGREE AND SO I
HOPE THAT WE WILL. CONTINUE TO
HAVE FRUITFUL EXCHANGES WITH.
THE CHINESE AND WITH WITH WITH
GOVERNMENTS AND PARTNERS ALL
OVER THE WORLD ABOUT HOW WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER TO COMBAT. THE
COMMON THREAD OF CLIMATE CHANGE
THAT WE FACE. AND AT THE SAME
TIME HAVE FRANK AND OPEN AND
HONEST CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUES THAT ARE SO
IMPORTANT SO WITH THAT I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY-
BUT JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CONTINUE. TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ON THESE ISSUES
GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU MR
GAVE. ANY OTHER. MR BERMAN.
THANK YOU GERMANY IN A AND- I'M
ONLY SITTING ON THIS COMMITTEE
TODAY SIR APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
PATIENCE BUT WE JUST WANT TO
FRANKLY- ALLOW MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF ALL MY COLLEAGUES
FROM- MARIN FROM SANTA MONICA
TO THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY-
I'LL BE VOTING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY BUT BUT I THINK IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE-
RAISE OUR VOICE- IN SUPPORT OF
THE WE ARE MUSLIMS- AND IN
OPPOSITION OF WHAT IS NOW BEEN
TURNED GENOCIDE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO THEM- AND IN
THEIR- INTERMENT CAMPS IN THIS
REGION PROVINCE AND- YOU KNOW
AS IT WE HAD A- PRESENTATION IN
THE JEWISH CAUCUS ABOUT THIS. A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO AND ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING- TO OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN IN
HUMANITY- AND WELL I THINK YOU
KNOW WE ALL HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO SPEAK UP WHEN WE SEE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT HAPPENING
IN THE WORLD AND I THINK WHAT
WE CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH WITH
THIS PARTNERSHIP TO COMBAT
CLIMATE CHANGE WHICH IS SUCH AN
EXISTENTIAL CRISIS IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
SPEAK UP- AND SPEAK OUT AGAINST
INJUSTICES THAT WE KNOW ARE
HAPPENING- YOU KNOW EVEN IN THE
COUNTRIES- IN YOU KNOW WHERE WE
MIGHT BE ALSO PARTNER
PARTNERING ON. ON TACKLING-
OTHER- EXISTENTIAL CRISIS SO-
I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY BUT BUT I REALLY TINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE SPEAK
OUT AGAINST WHAT'S HAPPENING-
TO HUMANS IN CHINA TO IT- WE
ARE MUSLIMS IN CHINA- AND YOU
KNOW THAT THAT WE TAKE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO STATE THAT THOSE
ARE NOT OUR VALUES THOSE ARE
NOT THINGS THAT WE STAND IN
SUPPORT OF- AND THOSE ARE
THINGS THAT WE DEMAND- THAT
THAT EVERY COUNTRY. IN THE
WORLD STOP IMMEDIATELY. THANK
YOU. THERE YOU MR BERMAN. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR CALL FROM
THE- DOES THE AUTHOR OF MAY
THAT'S ANY DOES THE OTHER ONE
TO MAKE IT. US ABSOLUTELY I A-
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO THANK
ALL MY COLLEAGUES WITH A VERY
THOUGHTFUL COMMENT AND LET ME
ADDRESS SO SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT'S BEEN RAISED AND STARTING
WITH THE OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
IRVINE- YOU MENTIONED THAT- YOU
KNOW THERE'S SO ALREADY IN
PLACES- INSTITUTE AND THERE'S
NO NEED TO DO SUCH A BILL IN
FACT THIS BILL AS I STARTED
ABOUT A YEAR AGO AND BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC. I WILL WE WEREN'T
ABLE T PROCEED WITH IT AND WE
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF A MADE BY
THE INSTITUTE BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA IS ALL ALWAYS AT THE
FOREFRONT WHEN IT COMES TO
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE THAT LEADERSHIP. AND
TO- MY COLLEAGUE FROM US IN
MARIN I THINK- WE COUNTY AND I
IDEA ME PER FACE YOU IF I MAY
AND YOU SAID THAT CHINA MUST BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION AND I
TOTALLY AGREE WITH. THAT AND I
THINK THAT- IN CALIFORNIA HAS
TO BUILD. A PUNISH. WITH
EVERYBODY WHO COULD REDUCE THIS.
OF YOU KNOW THIS IS SUCH A- NOW
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU ALSO.
I WAS BORN IN HONG KONG AND-
YOU KNOW YOU ALL KNOW WHAT'S
BEEN HAPPENING IN HONG KONG.
ALSO DISAGREE WITH A LOT OF THE
ISSUES THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING.
BUT I'D YOU KNOW WANTED TO
ISOLATE. MYSELF FROM A LOT OF
THE ISSUES THAT I CANNOT
CONTROL. BUT YET. I WANTED TO
FOCUS ON SOMETHING THAT I COULD
CONTROL. AND I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
DEFINITELY FOCUS IN ON. AND I
THINK THE GOVERNOR MENTIONED
FACT THAT CHINA IS A BIG
EMITTER. OF- CLOUT THESE ARE
THE KIND OF POLLUTION. AND
IMAGES THEIR SHARE WITH YOU
INTO. EIGHTEEN CHINA ADMITTED
TEN BILLION. METRIC TONS OF
CARBON DIOXIDE. AND JUST IN ONE
YEAR ALONE IN CALIFORNIA WE
WERE AT FOUR HUNDRED MILLION.
AND YES I THINK. IT IS IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF BOTH PARTIES
TO. WORK TO WHAT REDUCING THAT.
NUMBER I THINK. WHEN AND- WHEN
THE GOES DOWN TO. BENEFITS CAL.
CHINA AND ALSO MANY OF THE
NEIGHBORING. STATES AND ALSO
NEIGHBORING COUNTRIES SO THIS
IS SOME SOME KIND OF A- WIN WIN
SITUATION THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT. WE CAN AND SHOULD WORK
WITH CHINA ON ON SO SAID THAT
IS THE FOCUS ON A YOU KNOW OF
MY BILL. SO SO WITH THAT I
WANTED TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND I IT'S BEEN. IT'S BEEN A
GREAT DISCUSSION I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR. FOR
MAKING SUGGESTIONS AS WELL I
THINK A LOT FORWARD I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT WE
CAN DO ALSO. SO I AGAIN WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND YOUR TEAM
FOR YOU'LL WORK WITH MY TEAM
FOR THE LAST. A TWO- TWO WEEKS
SO I'M ON THIS BILL. SO- SO I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
FOR JOINING US AND FOR ALL THE
WORK THAT HE'S BEEN DOING. YOU
KNOW WITH A DONE TREMENDOUS
WORK AND- FORMER GOVERNOR BROWN
HAS BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT AND-
TAKING LEADERSHIP SO WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I WILL.
AND I TO THANK THE AUTHOR. IN
THIS LET'S. AND FOR GREEN TO
TAKE THE AMENDMENTS. AS
OUTLINED ON PAGE THREE OF THE
ANALYSIS. AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SAID. CLIMATE CHANGE IS
CERTAINLY A GLOBAL ISSUE. AND
CALIFORNIA PLAYS A KEY ROLE. IN
MAPPING PASS FORWARDS. THANKS
TO THE ONGOING WORK. THE
CALIFORNIA CHINA CLIMATE
INSTITUTE. OF BEFORE WE TAKE A
VOTE ON THE BILL. I'M GOING TO
TURN TO THE- SECRETARY. TO OPEN
UP TO VOTE AGAIN FOR. ADOPTION
OF THE COMMITTEE RULES AND THEN
WILL TAKE UP THE VOTE. MADAM
CHAIR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FOR A DOT OF THE
COMMITTEE RULES. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I BERMAN BERMAN HI
GABRIEL GABRIEL I IRWIN. IRWIN
I KILEY LOW. LOW I SANTIAGO.
THE TO VOTE IS TEN ZERO. TEN
ZERO THE COMMITTEE RULES ARE
PASSED WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ANY ABSENT MEMBERS I WE HAD
A FIRST BY MR LOW ON ON THIS
BILL I DO I SEE A SECOND ON THE
BILL. SECOND BY- MISTER. BLUM
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS DO PASS AT
THE AMENDED TO THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE. MEDINA HI
MEDINA HI CHOI. CHAU I KNOW
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI BERMAN
BERMAN I BLOOM. BLOOM HI
GABRIEL GABRIEL I IRWIN IRWIN I
KILEY LEVINE. LEVINE NOW LOW
LOW I SANTIAGO THE LDS. NOW
THERE IS NO. VOTE IS SEVEN
THREE THAT. YES IT THE LOTUS
SEVEN THREE THE BILL IS OUT WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MEMBERS. WE
ARE NOW GOING BACK. TWO FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE NINE- MR CHIU
PRESENTING A. B. TWO EIGHT
EIGHT FOR MR BONTA. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA TO
PRESENT AB TWO EIGHT EIGHT THE
CALIFORNIA BAN ON SCHOLARSHIP
DISPLACEMENT. WHICH WOULD
INCREASE ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION BY PREVENTING
COLLEGES FROM REDUCING
FINANCIAL AID AWARDS IF A
STUDENT ELIGIBLE FOR THE PELL
GRANTS FOR THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
ACT IS ALSO AWARDED A PRIVATE
SCHOLARSHIP. WE ALL KNOW THIS
MANY PARTICULAR THAT A DEGREE
AS EXPENSIVE. AND STUDENTS
STRUGGLE EVERY DAY TO MAKE ENDS
MEET. EVEN WITH STUDENT DEBT
AWARDS MANY STILL HAVE
FINANCIAL NEED AND WORK
EXTREMELY HARD TO EARN OUTSIDE
SCHOLARSHIPS. IN SOME CASES
STUDENTS ARE UNABLE TO MAKE
FULL USE OF AWARDS GIVEN BY
PRIVATE SCHOLARSHIP PROVIDERS
BECAUSE COLLEGES CAN REDUCE
THEIR FINANCIAL AID. WHICH
THOSE STUDENTS WOULD OTHERWISE
BE QUALIFIED TO RECEIVE. THIS
COMMON PRACTICE OF REDUCING
FINANCIAL AID AWARDS DUE TO THE
RECEIPT OF PRIVATE SCHOLARSHIPS
IS REFERRED TO. AS SCHOLARSHIP
pSTRUGGLE TO ACHIEVE THEIR
DREAMS WE MUST NOT PUNISH THOSE
WHO ARE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
RECEIVE A PRIVATE SCHOLARSHIP.
SCHOLARSHIP DISPLACEMENT
CREATES AN EVEN GREATER
FINANCIAL BURDEN ON STUDENTS
FROM LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES WHO
MAY NOT HAVE OTHER MEANS TO
PAY. FOR NON TUITION COSTS OF
COLLEGE BOOKS FOOD HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION. THE REAL COST
OF ATTENDING COLLEGE IS MUCH
MORE THAN THE TUITION AND FEES.
AND IT TENDS TO BE MUCH HIGHER
THAN TYPICAL FINANCIAL AID
AWARDS. A SMALL SCHOLARSHIP
MEANS THE BIG DIFFERENCE. KEEP
STUDENTS ON TRACK TO GRADUATE
INSTANCE INSTEAD OF BEING
FORCED TO DROP OUT. HEARING
SCHOLARSHIP. IS IMPORTANT. IN
ANY EQUITY FOCUSED COLLEGE
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF COVER
NINETEEN. AS PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
RESOURCES ARE BECOMING EVEN
MORE LIMITED FOR STUDENTS. THIS
BILL WOULD BRING US ONE STEP
CLOSER TO EQUITY ON OUR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES. AND HELP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS ACHIEVE
THEIR DREAM OF EARNING A
COLLEGE DEGREE AND WITH THAT
I'D LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO A
WITNESSES. MISTER THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR OPENING STATEMENT-
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR THE FIRST
LEAD WITNESS ON THE LINE FOR AB
TWO EIGHT EIGHT. IS MR FRANK
BOARD MEMBER OF OAKLAND PROMISE
MISTER FRANK PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU ARE READY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS IT'S MY HONOR TO BE
HERE TODAY MY NAME IS SHERRY
THANK I'M A RECENT GRADUATE OF
LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL IN OAKLAND
FROM ONE MEMBER AND A FRESHMAN
AT NY CD. DOUBLE ME IN CINEMA
DIGITAL MEDIA IN OPS. AT THE
PALATABLE BECAUSE THE L. A. B.
TWENTY EIGHT AFFECT. LIKE MANY
FOR GENERATION LOW INCOME
COLLEGE STUDENTS. BEING TO FOR
CALL ND OUT OF IT THREE ALL
THE BEEN MY TO. IT MOTIVATED ME
PUSHED. IT'S A GREAT. AND GO
ABOVE AND BE IT EVERYTHING THAT
CAN. IF YOU'VE GOT CALL
CRITICAL. YEAH ME MAKE THAT
THREE OF THE- TODAY I'M VERY TO
BE DEFEATING OF THE OPEN CALL
JEFF. AND ANOTHER THOUGHT OF
OFFER MONEY TO. BUT EVEN THEN
I'LL STILL HAVE THE TAKE OUT A
TO. I WANTED TO FOR THE MARK
SHIPS BUT I WOULD VERY WHEN THE
HIGH SCHOOL BY COMMITTEE. HE'S
OKAY COLD. FORTY ORGANIZATIONS
BEING A WORKING STUDENT WHEN
MCCREE BEYOND STRESSFUL. IT IS
DIFFICULT TO WORK I THINK I
FOUND MYSELF WHEN I MANY
THINKING CLICKING A CLIPBOARD.
AND WORKING UNTIL FOUR AM
THEY'RE WAKING UP EARLY TO GO
TO CLASS EVERY MORNING BECOME A
NORM. I DO HAVE TIME TO OTHER.
TO SPEND TIME FRIENDS AND
FAMILY IT CARE MYSELF UP IN MY
FIELD IN ARTIST. IT'S AB EIGHT
WITH THEIR AND IF I WERE GIVEN
THE ABILITY TO APPLY THE
PRIVATE SENSE WITH MY EIGHTEEN
PLACED. OKAY EXPERIENCE AND
INVEST TIME INTO CRISTINA
KILLED DON'T TO THE COURT THAT
I BY BE. BUT TODAY I ASK FOR
ALL SUPPORT ON. EIGHTY EIGHT.
HOWARD DURING A COMMUNITY I
THINK E. R. HOLLISTER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS FANG
EIGHTEEN TO MODERATE THIS I
LEAD WITNESS CAR IT IS MARCO
ONE THIS A POLICY CONSULT FOR
THIS CAL. COLLEGE ACCESS
NETWORK. MISTER MONTE PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MARK WHAT
MONTH IT AND- I'M POLICY
CONSULTANT TO ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE ACCESS
NETWORK COMPANIES BOTH OF MORE.
THAN ONE HUNDRED COLLEGE
EXCLUSION ACT THAT'S WORKING
EFFICIENT AND THE TALENT
CALIFORNIA REGION AND
COLLECTIVELY PROVIDE SUPPORTS
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS. AND FAMILIES
AND THE CHANGES TO HIGHER
EDUCATION. I'M HERE TODAY TO
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY TO
EIGHTY EIGHT IMPACT POLICY
DISPLACEMENT. THANK YOU FOR
BACK PAIN THAT I'LL MAKE THE
MOST SCHOLARSHIP THE PLACEMENT
BACK IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN ONE AT
OUTLOOK THAT GET MEMBER OF THE
CATHOLIC STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
ALKER RELIEF TO KNOW THAT IN MY
FIFTH AND FINAL YEAR OF COLLEGE
APPLICANTS RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
EIGHT DOLLARS TO SUPPORT MY
COLLEGE EXPENSES. ALDON SHOPS
TURNED ON MY FINANCIAL AID
PACKAGE HAVE BEEN DECREASED THE
FACT THAT I WAS RECEIVING
EXTERNAL SCHOLARSHIP DOLLARS IN
ORDER FOR ME TO ACCESS OF VALOR
STATUS ARE YOU TELLING SERVICE
IF YOU IF YOU DID IN FACT HAVE
TO ADJUST MY LIVING
ARRANGEMENT. AND MOVE OUT OF MY
HOME SO THAT MAKE. IT WOULD NOT
DISPLAY. MY STORY IS NOT UNIQUE
STUDENTS ACROSS CARD BACKED UP.
FOR THAT. COULD MAC SCHOLARSHIP
WORK AND EVEN WITHIN ALL PAY
FOR THE- OF COLLEGE. BUT OFTEN
THE DENTAL LIKE THE IN TWO WHAT
HOW MUCH STATE THEY- RECEIVE. I
THANK- DON'T YOU A GREAT ACTOR.
THAT THEY HAVE TO DISPLAYED
BECAUSE- ARE NOT TRANSPARENT
ABOUT. THE COPPER TENETS
SITTING IN A HOME THE PARENTS
AT AT THE MEANT TO BE THAT.
DOSE FORMULA TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
ACCIDENTS. YOU CONTRIBUTING TO
AT SUPPORTING- HOW COULD IT.
NOT GREAT AND BILLS. THAT
DAMAGE THAT PANDEMIC MARKETS
EIGHT DOLLAR ARE HOW GOOD AT
BANGKOK. BUT THEIR STUDENT THAT
EXTRA MONEY HAND TO BE TO PAY
FOR. EXPENSES CAN BE A
PERMANENT OR NOT THAT YOU DON'T.
THE FACT TO CONTINUE THEIR. TO
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS CAN. YEAR
SO HOW CAN SALAS PROVIDE AND
HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERN. WHAT
DID A PACK. OF SPEAKING EIGHT.
SCHOLARS DOLLARS ARE. FOR HIGH.
IN OLD DEACON STUDENTS WHO WORK
HARD TO AND- CONSCIOUS- TO
COVER THE CAR. BEYOND TUITION.
SCHOLARSHIP THE CENTER BACK TO
SKINNER DONORS. LOCAL COMMUNITY.
FROM GIVING AT THE FROM ACROSS.
AB EIGHT EIGHT PROTECT LOW
CONSTRAIN FIND I GOING TO.
UTILIZE IN AN EFFORT TO PRIVATE
CLOSER TO OUR- TO COVER THE
COST OF COLLEGE UNIT THINK I'M-
RATE COVER THE- TUITION. DID
WILL HELP OVER NINETEEN THIRTY
EIGHT. POUNDS AND RESEARCH. AND
WITHOUT. CALIFORNIA. AT THE
PROBABLY EIGHT TO TEN COMMON
COMPETE AGREES. AKERSHUS NEARBY
IN FAVOR AB TWO EIGHT THANK
VERY IN FACT. THEY YOU MISTER
MANTAS WE WILL NOW TO PAY
COMMENT. OUR THERE ANY WOULD IN
THE OF THE AND GALLERY NOT SEEN
ANY ANYWAY. AND I'M- TO THE
CHAMBER AND A GALLERY I SEEN
ANY ANY TWEENER NO NOT SEEN ANY.
MOVEMENT OF THE PHONE LINES
ANTI MATTER ANY WITNESS AND
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE OR IN THE
QUEUE. YES MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE- PEOPLE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
MCGINLEY'S GERMAN IF YOU DO
WISH TO COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO IT'S TIME. NOW GO
TO LINE THIRTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING REBECCA GONZALEZ OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE. NINE
THIRTY. MORNING MEDIA RODRIGUEZ
WE HAVE TO EDUCATION TRUST WEST
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BY.
TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
THREE OTHER THING NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. LINE.
THIRTY SIX. MEMBERS ON THE
ASSEMBLY SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. LINE.
THIRTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING FACE
ANY THAT'LL FALL PLAN WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATE IN SUPPORT OF
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
LINE. TWENTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME'S KALISTO DIRECTOR
POLICY FOR SCULPTURE AMERICA
AND YOU WANTED TO- WHERE THE
NATION'S LARGEST NONPROFITS
CAUGHT FIRE AND WE WANTED TO
URGE- MEMBERS OF THE FAMILY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL WE OFFER OUR
SUPPORT SMALL. NINE THIRTY
EIGHT. UNDERTAKEN ON BEHALF OF
THE STUDENT SENATE KAPERNICK
MANY COLLEGES IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWO TWO A DAY. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. THANK YOU MODERATOR-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANY ON
THE QUEUE OR ON THE LINE. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
THIS PRESS ONE ANSWER AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIR NO ONE IS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK AT THIS TIME. MISTER
MODERATOR ANY TWEETERS. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK
AT THIS TIME. PAST WINNERS.
THIS PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. SURE
NO ONE IS SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU I
TURNED TO THE COMMITTEE. MR
GABER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR- AND I JUST WANTED
TO- SORT OF RACE IT'S SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN A QUESTION AND A
COMMENT AND- I KNOW WE HAVE OUR
COLLEAGUE- YOU KNOW HE'S BEING
OUT OF LOYALTY MASON KIDDING
SELF NOTWITHSTANDING THE FACT
THAT HE'S- AMONG OUR MOST
ACCOMPLISHED AND INTELLIGENT
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW THAT HE'S
GOT THE ANSWER TO THIS ONE M.
YEAH JUST BECAUSE HE SOMETHING
AND QUITE ONE THING THAT
OCCURRED TO ME AND MY STAFF AS
WE WERE LOOKING AT THE BILL
WISE- YOU KNOW FIRST OF ALL HOW
MUCH WE SUPPORT THE PURPOSE OF
IT- YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S
SHAMEFUL HOW MUCH WE UNDER
FUND- PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
IN THE STATE. AND HOW LISTENING
TO THE TESTIMONY OF SOME OF THE
WITNESSES ABOUT HOW THEY
STRUGGLE TO PUT THEMSELVES
THROUGH SCHOOL I MEAN THAT IS
NOT A SITUATION THAT ANY OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE SHOULD BE AND. AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO ON
THAT FRONT. THAT I'M INSTEAD IS.
I WAS LOOKING AT THE BILL I WAS
TRYING TO. UNDERSTAND IS. IS
THE PRACTICAL IMPACT OF THIS
BILL GOING TO BE THAT IT
CONCENTRATES RESOURCES. IN THE
HANDS OF A- SMALL NUMBER
STUDENTS RATHER THAN SPENDING
THEM OUT MORE BROADLY. AND IS
THAT GOING TO IMPACT. IN SOME
WAYS OUR MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS I ASSUME THAT OF THOSE
RECEIVING FINANCIAL AID- THAT.
THAT ARE MOST VULNERABLE- FROM
THE- FROM THE MOST DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE GOING TO BE
LEAST LIKELY TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS- PRIVATE SCHOLARSHIP
THEY MAY NOT KNOW ABOUT THAT.
AND SO- YOU KNOW THIS THIS IS
YOUR SCHOLARSHIP DISPLACEMENT
UNDERSTAND WHY THAT WOULD BE
EXTRAORDINARILY CHALLENGING.
AND WORRISOME FOR STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN PRIVILEGED TO RECEIVE
MULTIPLE SCHOLARSHIPS BUT IF WE
CONCENTRATE. RESOURCES AND
THEIR HANDS ARE WE LIMITING THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
GOING TO GET FINANCIAL AID AND
THEN PERHAPS. INADVERTENTLY
CLOSING THE DOORS. OF HIGHER
EDUCATION TO SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS AND- YOU
KNOW I DON'T KNOW I IN AND-
POTENTIALLY IS. IF I GUESS WHAT
I'M HOPING TO HEAR FROM FROM
FOLKS WHO SUPPORT THE SPELL-
IS. YOU KNOW ARE WE TAKING THAT
DISCRETION AWAY FROM FROM
FINANCIAL AID OFFICERS
UNIVERSITIES YOU MIGHT LOOK AT
THIS AND SAY WELL THE STUDENT
HAS RECEIVED. A NUMBER OF
PRIVATE SCHOLARSHIPS. NOT
EVERYTHING I HOPE BUT IT'S
ENOUGH TO GET THEM IN HERE AND
I'D LIKE TO SHIFT SOME OF THAT
LIMITED RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE.
TO ANOTHER STUDENT WHO WON'T BE
ABLE TO ATTEND THIS UNIVERSITY
WITHOUT THOSE RESOURCES SO. I'M
NOT SURE WHAT THE- WHAT THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION IS I'M
PREPARED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY BECAUSE THE OFFER IS NOT
HERE AND I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION THAT.
THAT DESERVES TO CONTINUE- BUT
EITHER. TODAY FROM SOME OF THE
WITNESSES OR OR PERHAPS A THE
FUTURE CONVERSATION WITH THE
AUTHOR- FOR MY GREAT RESPECT I
I'M I'M JUST CURIOUS ABOUT- ARE
WE INADVERTENTLY. GOING TO BE
SENDING SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS. OUT OF
HIGHER ED. BY CONCENTRATING
RESOURCES. IN THE HANDS OF
ELECTED YEAH. THANK YOU MR
GABRIEL ANY OTHER. QUESTIONS
DOES. RESEARCH IF YOU WANT TO
OKAY FINE I'LL GIVE A PARTIAL
ANSWER TO THIS SO- FIRST OF ALL
IN ONE THANKS COMMITTEE STAFFER
POINTED OUT THE FINANCIAL AID
OFFICERS DO NOT TAKE A POSITION
ON THIS BILL NOR THE EXPRESS
THAT PARTICULAR CONCERN AND I
KNOW THAT'S NOT THE INTENT OF
THE AUTHOR. AND HE'S OPEN TO
THIS CONVERSATION ONE THING
I'LL THE SEMI OWN BEHALF IS
THIS PRACTICE HAS CREATED A
VIRTUALLY DAY DISINCENTIVE FOR
PRIVATE SCHOLARSHIP PROVIDERS
BECAUSE IT. BASICALLY SENDS A
SIGNAL THAT IF THEY'RE
CONTRIBUTE THEIR DOLLARS THAT-
THAT THEIR DOLLARS WILL BE USED
TO BACKFILL INSTITUTIONAL EIGHT
SO FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE THE
QUESTION IS WHY WOULD I GIVE MR
GABRIEL A SCHOLARSHIP IF THAT'S
GONNA TAKE AWAY SOMETHING ELSE
HE'S DOING SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT WE ARE PROPERLY AND
SENDING THOSE PRIVATE
SCHOLARSHIP PROVIDERS TO DO
WHAT THEY DO- BUT OBVIOUSLY
I'VE LITERALLY JUST STEPPED IN
TEN MINUTES AGO SO I'M SURE
THERE ARE OTHER PERSPECTIVES ON
THIS AS WELL. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. MISTER MEDINA I
PLEDGE MISTER WITH THAT THANK
YOU- AND AGAIN I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE MR BONTA IS NOT HERE
TODAY I DID HAVE THE SAME
CONCERNS AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL- OF THE BUT ALSO. I
HAVE BEEN MEMBER OF A NUMBER OF
CLUBS THAT HAVE OFFERED THE
SMALL SCHOLARSHIPS AND- TO
STUDENTS AND THERE WAS ALWAYS A
CONCERN. OR OR THERE WAS A REAL
INTEREST IN WRITING THE CHECKS
TO THE INSTITUTION FOR TUITION
AND SO MY CONCERN WOULD BE IF
CALIFORNIA NOW STEPS IN AND
SAYS NO YOU HAVE TO WRITE THE
CHECK TO THE STUDENT BECAUSE
THE TUITION IS ALREADY BEING
COVERED BY THE SCHOOL. I'M
CONCERNED THAT YOU MIGHT LOSE A
LOT OF- SMALL SCHOLARSHIP SO
HAS HAS THAT- BEEN CONSIDERED
OR DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHETHER
IT'S BEEN CONSIDERED OR NOT.
MOST DEMOCRATS. WHICH VERSION
SHOULD GIVE I ACTUALLY DON'T
KNOW THE ANSWER THEM JUST
CONFIRM WITH COMMITTEE STAFF
AND YOU KNOW WHAT AT NIGHT I
WILL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY BUT
I THINK THAT SOME OF THESE
DETAILS NEED TO BE WORKED OUT
YOU DON'T WANT IT AND THEN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE THAT A
LOT OF THESE SMALL PRIVATE
SCHOLARSHIP- THAT- THAT A LOT.
THE SMALL PRIVATE SCHOLARSHIPS
END UP DISAPPEARING BECAUSE OF
SOMETHING THAT WE DID HERE AT
THE LEGISLATURE. AGAIN I'D
APPRECIATE THAT WELL. TWO TWO.
I APOLOGIZE I CAN ACTUALLY NOT
ABLE TO RESIST- BUT BUT I'LL
JUST I'LL JUST SAY AGAIN THAT
T THIS MOMENT THERE IS A
STRANGE DISINCENTIVE TO THOSE
CULTURE PROVIDERS BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THAT THEY PROVIDE A
SCHOLARSHIP TO YOU- THAT THAT
WILL END UP NOT INCREASING THE
AMOUNT OF HELP THAT THE STUDENT
GETS- BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT-
THAT THAT- THE OFFERING
COMMITTEE ARE AWARE OF THIS
CONCERN AND- WILL CERTAINLY
PASS IT ON TO MR BONTA TO
ADDRESS THAT WITH YOU. IN THE
COMING DAYS. AND ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE- ST JUDE YOU WANNA
MAKE A CLOSING STATEMENT
ADDRESS ON BEHALF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU. AND- THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR BRING UP-
CONCERNS AND I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT YOU KNOW HAVING HAD A
DAUGHTER. IN COLLEGE WHO DID
RECEIVE SCHOLARSHIPS- AND THAT
SHE WAS ABLE TO. TO TAKE EVERY
DOLLAR THAT SHE WAS OFFERED IN
SCHOLARSHIP MONEY. AND THE
INSTITUTION A PRIVATE
INSTITUTION WAS ACTUALLY ABLE
TO DOUBLE IT. YOU KNOW. SOME
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ARE HEARD
BY- THE PRACTICE OF TAKING AWAY
MANY. WHEN THEY RECEIVED
ADDITIONAL MONEY SO I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE- THE OTHER BRING IN
THIS MEASURE FOR AND I THINK WE
NEED TO ENSURE DO WHATEVER W
CAN TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS ARE
ARE ABLETO RECEIVE EVERY
ELIGIBLE DOLLAR FOR THE
COLLEGES EXPENSES I THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR A WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS IS NOTED
ON PAGE FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS.
IS THERE A MOTION. C. MOVE BY
MR WAY SECOND. SECOND BUT MR
BLOOM- MADAM SECRETARY BUTTE
WOULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. YES
MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA HI CHOI. CHOI I
ARAMBULA BERMAN BLOOM BLOOM HI
GABRIEL. GABRIEL I IRWIN- WHEN
I KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I LOW.
SANTIAGO CALAVERAS MELENDEZ HI.
THE VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO. THE
LOTUS SEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU MISTER CHOI FOR
PRESENTING FOR MR BONTA AND WE
WILL GO NOW TO THE THIRD. ITEM.
AB TWO FORTY FIVE. MR CHIU A
MEDICARE COLLEAGUES APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL.
ENTER NON BINARY STUDENTS FACE
MANY BARRIERS IN SCHOOL AND IN
THE WORKPLACE IF A STUDENT
DOESN'T HAVE AN UPDATED DIPLOMA
OR TRANSCRIPT THEY CAN FACE
CHALLENGES APPLYING FOR
GRADUATE SCHOOL OR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. IT DIPLOMA IS A
REPRESENTATION OF YEARS OF HARD
WORK AND ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT.
IT SHOULDN'T COST STRESS OR
EMOTIONAL HARM BY HAVING
SOMEONE'S DEAD NAME ON IT DUE
TO OUTDATED SCHOOL FALLS. AT
THE PALM OF THAT HAS THE WRONG
NAME CAN HAVE EFFECTIVE OUTING
SOMEONE. WHO DOES NOT WISH TO
BE ADDED OR MAY FEEL UNSAFE AND
THEIR CURRENT SITUATION COMING
OUT AS TRANSGENDER OR NON
BINARY. THIS BILL DOES TWO
THINGS IT ALLOWS TRANSGENDER
AND NON BINARY STUDENTS AT
PUBLIC COLLEGES. TO HAVE THEIR
CHOSEN NAME PRINTED ON THE
DIPLOMA WHEN THEY GRADUATE.
SECONDLY IT ALSO CREATES A
STANDARD PROCESS FOR UPDATING
STUDENT RECORDS OF FORMER
STUDENTS. SO THAT THEIR NAME
AND GENDER ACTUALLY REFLECT ON
IMPORTANT RECORDS. THIS BILL
BUILDS UPON A LAW THAT I OFFER
IN TWENTY NINETEEN. TO MAKE
SURE THAT FORMER K. TWELVE
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO UPDATE
STUDENT RECORDS TO MATCH THE
CORRECT NAME AND SINCE THEN
WE'VE HEARD FROM COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND GRADUATES WHO FACE
SIMILAR CHALLENGES AND SUNNY TO
EXTEND THIS POLICY TO PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
TRANSBOUNDARY PEOPLE FACED A
LOT OF BARRIERS THE NAME OF THE%
DIPLOMA. SHOULD NOT BE ANOTHER
THING THEY HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
AND WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO OR WITNESSED I WANT TO THANK
OUR SPONSOR FOR QUALITY
CALIFORNIA. A MISTER JUNE
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR THE LEAD
WITNESS CALLING IN. IS TAMMY
MARTIN LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR AT
EQUITY CALIFORNIA. MISS MARTIN
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING-SHERRY COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE
CANYON MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WE'RE VERY
PROUD TO BE HERE TODAY AS THE
BUNKER OF EIGHTY TWO FORTY FIVE
WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT FORMER
STUDENTS WILL BE ABLE TO OBTAIN
OF ACADEMIC RECORDS LIKE
DIPLOMA AND TRANSCRIPT.
ACCURATELY REFLECT THEIR LEGAL
NAME AND GENDER REGARDLESS OF
WHEN THEY GRADUATED THE BILL
ALSO SPECIFIES THAT A
GRADUATING STUDENT NAY EASILY
HAVE THEIR CHOSEN NAMES LISTED
ON THEIR DIPLOMA WHICH IS A
CEREMONIAL BUT STILL PERSONALLY
SIGNIFICANT DOCUMENT. I WOULD
NEED RECORDS DON'T REFLECT THE
CORRECT INFORMATION TRANSGENDER
AND NON BINARY STUDENTS WHO
KNEW THE TRANSCRIPT FOR EXAMPLE
TO APPLY FOR JOBS OR OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES I PUT AT RISK OF
DISCRIMINATION OR HARM AT THE
AUTHOR HAS JUST MENTIONED. AND
THE COMPOUND THE SOCIETAL
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING TECHNOLOGY COULD YOU
PRACTICAL ALREADY FACE CERTAIN
THE COMMONSENSE BILL AND IT
WILL ADDRESS INEQUITY IT WILL
SAFEGUARD THE PRIVACY OF ALL
GRADUATES INCLUDING TRANSGENDER
AND NON BINARY GRADUATES AND
ENSURE THAT I COULD YOU CASE
ALL RECORDS ARE ACCURATE SO
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EXCUSE FOR BEING A
CHAMPION FOR THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY. AND FOR OFFERING
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE AND
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT. TODAY AS WELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU MS
MARTIN WE WILL MOVE THE-
COMMENT. NOT SEEN ANY. IN THE-
OR IN THE GALLERY. NO WITNESSES
IN THE OF THE NO TWEETERS WE
WILL GO NOW TO THE PHONE LINE
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE OR IN THE QUEEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AMENITY IF YOU DO IT THIS TIME
WISH TO COMMENT AND PAPER THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WELL FIRST TWO
FROM THE LINE OF THIRTY ONE THE
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN FROM THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE TO SUPPORT. PINE. THIRTY
NINE. YOUR TURN MEMBERS ON THE
ASSEMBLY SHOT ON THE NOTHING
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND ITS WORK THANK
YOU. LINE. FORTY BUT ONE THAT
OPENED. PROTECTING GONZALEZ
NATIONAL EXPECTATION THAT THOSE
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. LINE. TWENTY FOUR.
TRANSACTION NATURE YOUR
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FINE. THIRTY EIGHT. THE PROJECT.
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHEN I INTERNET GONNA BE HAPPY
STUDENT CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
RECALLED IS STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE TWO FORTY FIVE. NO ONE ELSE
TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. OKAY I'M STEVEN CHOI
VICE CHAIR AND THEN OUR CHAIR
PERSON HAS TO LEAVE FOR CANADA-
COMMITTEE AND THE WOULD BE BACK
ON IS THERE ANY IF THAT'S SO-
PERSON PERCENT- TO MAKE SURE IF
THERE'S ANY COMMENTS OF FROM
ALL MEMBERS COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NO NO PROMISE OF FROM THE
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE- OF WHAT
IS THAT IMPORTANT AB AT TWO
FORTY FIVE- EVEN MYSELF I
EXPERIENCED IT MYSELF AND NOT
NAME CHANGE ILLEGALLY- TO MAKE
IT UP CORRECT AT THE- THAT THE
NAME. THE SOUND OF THE NAME-
ORDERED A QUESTION THE
REFLECTIVE SO- WHEN- I NEED TO
OF THE CHANGE ORDER
DOCUMENTATION AND THE DIPLOMA I
THINK THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
THE BILL SO- I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL- I WOULD
LIKE TO ENTERTAIN ANY MOTION.
TO ADOPT THIS BILL. OKAY MEMBER
LEVY SECOND. OKAY MISTER ROOM.
ALL RIGHT- CLUBS GO HEAD OF
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA.
CHOI HI CHOI I ARAMBULA BERMAN
BLOOM BLOOM HI GABRIEL GABRIEL
I IRWIN. IRWIN I KILEY. LEVINE
LEVINE I LOW SANTIAGO
BALLADARES VALDEZ HI. OKAY THE
VOTE SIX ZERO. LEAVE IT ON
CALLS YEAH IT'S A NICE ALRIGHT
WILL BE PRESENTING MY IDEAL I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK OUR MEMBER
BLOOM- TO PRESIDE WHILE I'M
PRESENTING THE BILL. NUMBER
FOUR NUMBER FOUR OKAY ALL
RIGHTS OR A NUMBER FOR EIGHTY
TO FIFTY ONE MISTER CHOI. OKAY
THANK YOU- TEMPORARY CHAIR
BLOOM- I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT US
AB TWO FIFTY ONE- THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT- A. B.
TWO FIFTY ONE OF WHICH WOULD TO
BRING NECESSARY CLARIFICATION
TO THE COLLEGE ADMISSION BY
EXCEPTION PROCESS UP AT THE CSU
AND UC. AND HELP PROTECT THAT
THIS PROCESS AGAINST OF FRAUD
AND ABUSE. AS YOU ARE AWARE-
ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO OUR HOW
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
OF WORSHIP AND BY THE LARGEST A
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS A SCANDAL IN
THE HISTORY OF THE U. S. WHAT.
BECAME KNOWN AS OPERATION
VARSITY BLUES- INVOLVED A
SEVERAL YEARS OF- INVESTIGATION
BY THE FBI AND THE ARREST OF
OVER FIFTY INDIVIDUAL ALSO
INVOLVED IN RACKETEERING
BRIBERY. AND WIRE FRAUD IN
ORDER TO SECURE ADMISSION IS UP
AT THE AT LEAST UNIVERSITIES
FOR THEY ARE CHILDREN.
FORTUNATELY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE ROSE TO THE
OCCASION IN ACTING AB. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE BY MY COLLEAGUES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY WHOM I
AM ALSO PROUD TO HAVE A AS A
JOINT ALSO ON MY A. B. TWO
FIFTY ONE. AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE AMONG OTHER THINGS A
BROUGHT UP IMPORTANT OVERSIGHT
TO THEADMISSION BY EXCEPTION
PROCESS WHICH ALLOWS THE US. TO
ARGUE WITH SOME CALIFORNIA TO
ENROLL UP 26% OF A START UP
BECAUSE OF WHO DO NOT MEET THE
UC ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS BUT
OTHERWISE- DEMONSTRATES HIGH
POTENTIAL FOR SUCCESS IN ORDER
TO PROTECT AGAINST THE KIND OF-
ABUSE THAT THAT WE SAW IN THE
OPERATION VARSITY BLUES OF
SCANDAL. AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE REQUIRED THIS ADMISSION
BY EXCEPTION CANDIDATES- TO BE
REVIEWED BY. A PANEL OF- THREE
SEED CAMPUS UP AND MISS.
HOWEVER IT DID NOT DEFY WHO ON
AT THE TEMPERS COULD OR COULD
NOT PARTICIPATE IN THE
ADMISSION BY EXCEPTION PROCESS.
NPR COMMITTEE ON ALICE'S SAW A
POINTS OUT STP- COMMITTEE ON
ALICE'S UP POINT OFF NINE
POINTS OUT- SINCE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF OFFICES ARE NOT
ALWAYS THE ONLY DEPARTMENT
CHARGE OF THE WITH A CAMPUS
DEVELOPMENT AND THE FUNDRAISING
AT THE UC OR CSU AB TWO FIFTY
ONE REMOVES ANY DOUBT OF- UNDO
OR IMPROPER INFLUENCE. ON A
MISSION SO DECISIONS BY
PROHIBITING A STAFF OF
ASSOCIATE IT WITH THE EXTERNAL
RELATIONS ACTIVITIES OF FROM
PROVIDING ON A COMMISSION
DECISION FOR. OUR INCOMING
STUDENTS CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
THE MOST EXCEPTIONAL HIGH YOUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM IN THE WORLD.
IT IS A TRAGEDY CHORE AND-
CENTRAL TO OUR SUCCESS AS
SOMEONE OF THE STRONGEST
ECONOMIES AND THE VIBRANT
DIVERSE POPULATION. IN THE
COUNTRY. HOWEVER HAVING MYSELF-
RECEIVE A QUALITY EDUCATION AND
EVENTUALLY MY PHD IN- I
PERSONALLY KNOW THAT ARE YA
COULD NOT BE SITTING HERE-
BEFORE YOUR SO LAWMAKER IF IT
WERE NOT DAHLE FOR EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES WE MUST. TAKE
BACK EVERY STEP TO PRESERVE
ABOUT THIS EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES SO FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND TO PROTECT
AGAINST THE TYPE OF ABUSE AND
THE FROG THAT WAS A REVEALS
JUST A FEW YEARS AGO A. B. TWO
FIFTY ONE BUILDS UPON IMPORTANT
STEPS TO STRENGTHEN OUR
ADMISSION BY EXCEPTION PROCESS
AND THEN ENSURE FAIR EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO QUALITY HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR DO SERVING
CALIFORNIA'S. FOR THIS REASON
SO. I RESPECT ASK OF YOUR
pIPHONE. ON TO AB TWO FIFTY ONE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIR MODERATOR THERE ARE NO
LEAD WITNESSES SCHEDULED TO BE
HEARD FOR THIS BILL WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OF THE BILL OR IN OPPOSITION IN
THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER FLOOR
OR IN THE GALLERY. I'M SEEING
NONE- ARE THERE ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK. BUT
ARE NOT FOR OR AGAINST THE BILL.
WHO ARE HERE. IN THE CHAMBER IN
THE GALLERY SEEING NONE WE WILL
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT WHO ARE ON THE PHONE
OR IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS.
ONE NINE ZERO. SURE NO ONE IS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
PEAK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU-
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WHO ARE ON THE PHONE
OR IN THE QUEUE. AND AGAIN
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
SURE NO ONE IS SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU FINALLY
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES WHO-
WOULD SIMPLY LIKE TO ADD
COMMENTS. AND EITHER FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL. THANKS FOR
YOUR COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO. NO ONE IS SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. MR
GABRIEL. Q- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TODAY JUST WANTED TO
ADD A COMMENT AND- YEAH I
CERTAINLY THINK THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT ISSUE
AND IS A GRADUATE OF UC
BERKELEY ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I'M PROUDEST OF IS THAT I CAN
TELL PEOPLE THAT I WAS ADMITTED
TO. THE UC SYSTEM NOT BECAUSE
OF WHO MY FAMILY WAS OR
ANYTHING ABOUT MY PERSONAL
BIOGRAPHY OTHER THAN THAT I
WORKED REALLY HARD IN COLLEGE
AND SO I THINK THAT THAT THE-
THE EMISSIONS SCANDAL
CERTAINLY- A BLACK GUY FOR OUR
TREASURE UC SYSTEM. THAT I'M
INSIDE I JUST WANT TO ADD A
FRIENDLY- DOSE OF SKEPTICISM
ABOUT THIS BILL- I HOPE IT'S
EXPECTED IN THAT MATTER THAT. I
DIDN'T INCREDIBLY TONE DEAF FOR
NEEDY INSTITUTIONS TO- YOU KNOW
A TO A TO A SIGNED TODAY TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY OF THE FOLKS THAT
ARE IDENTIFIED IN THIS BILL I
DON'T THINK ANYONE WOULD BE.
QUITE THAT QUITE THAT TURNED
OUT TO DO THAT. AND IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT IF THERE IS AN
INSTITUTION THAT IS INTENT ON
GOING AROUND THE RULES THEN
THE- HEAD OF FINANCIAL AID IS
JUST GOING TO ASK WHOEVER'S ON
THE IGNITION BY EXCEPTION
COMMITTEE TO GO HAVE A DRINK AT
THE UNIVERSITY CLUB TO TALK
ABOUT IT. SO I THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT EFFORT- BUT I'M NOT
EXACTLY SURE WHAT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IS GOING TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT HAVING BEEN
SAID I UNDERSTAND THE TAX I
WILL BE VOTING FOR IT. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL GO
BEARS. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE IS THERE A AND IS THE
AUTHOR OF WHICH PROVIDE CLOSING
STATE. I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. IF YOU HAVE A MOTION.
IS THERE A SECOND MR LOS MOVING.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A SECOND.
LET'S HAVE A ROLL CALL VOTE.
THE MOTION BEFORE US IS TO PASS
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. MEDINA CHOI YES
CHOI HI ARAMBULA. BERMAN. BLOOM
HI LOOM II GABRIEL. GABRIEL I
IRWIN. WHEN I KILEY LEVINE
LEVINE I LOW. HELLO HI SANTIAGO
HELLO. VALDEZ HI. THE VOTE IS
SEVEN ZERO. LOTUS SEVEN ZERO
THAT IS A PATH THAT LEADS OUT.
THANK YOU WILL MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LAURIE DAVIES OTHER. WELCOME
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT TO YOU AB FIVE FORTY
THREE. I'D FIRST LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF TO AMEND THE BILL
TO WIDEN THE REQUIREMENTS TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND I WILL
BE ACCEPTING THIS AMENDMENT. AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW CALFRESH IS A
SUPPLEMENTARY NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE BENEFIT PROGRAM
ALLOCATED TO THE STATE BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IS
DISTRIBUTED TO ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS BY EACH COUNTY.
THERE ARE MANY ADVANTAGES CAL
FIRST ESPECIALLY FOR COLLEGE
STUDENTS. WHO ARE SUPPORTING
THEMSELVES THROUGH COLLEGE ARE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
EVEN WITH CURRENT LAWS THERE
ARE STILL SO MANY COLLEGE
STUDENTS THAT ARE UNAWARE OF
THE CALIFORNIA PROGRAM.
AVAILABLE TO THEM WHICH IS WHY
EIGHTY FIVE FORTY THREE IS SO
IMPORTANT. ORIENTATION IS A ONE
TIME FOR ALMOST ALL STUDENTS
ARE REQUIRED TO ATTEND. IT IS A
PLACE FOR STUDENTS TO LEARN
ABOUT THE COLLEGE AND RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO THEM. WITH THE
DATA THAT HAS BEEN COLLECTED
FROM THE THREE PUBLIC SYSTEMS
IN THE STATE IT IS NOTED THAT
THE PARTICIPATION RATE AMONG
COLLEGE STUDENTS IS BETWEEN
EIGHTY EXCUSE ME EIGHTEEN AT
THIRTY PERCENT. LEAVING
ESTIMATED ONE MILLION CALFRESH
BENEFITS UNCLAIMED EVERY MONTH.
KELLY STUDENTS ARE EITHER NOT
RECEIVING ENOUGH INFORMATION OR
UNAWARE OF THE BENEFITS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM. WITH
THIS AMOUNT OF MONEY THE TABLE
WE NEED TO SPREAD
DISINFORMATION TO COLLEGES. SO
THAT WE CAN PREVENT PRUDENT
SECURITY FOR ALL STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH WILL ALLOW
THEM. TO FOCUS ON THE
EDUCATIONAL AND PROFESSIONAL
GOALS. AND ON A PERSONAL NOTE I
CAN TELL YOU THAT. IF I WOULD
HAVE THIS PROGRAM. WHEN I WAS
IN COLLEGE IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
VERY- IT WOULD BEEN VERY
REASSURING. I CAME FROM
WISCONSIN I DROVE OUT HERE
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL- I WENT TO
CAL STATE. LONG BEACH BUT I
STARTED AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN LONG BEACH. I WORKED
TWO JOBS TO PAY FOR MY REFUSE
TO PAY FOR MY RENT PAID FOR MY
FOOD PAPER MY UTILITIES. I CAN
TELL YOU THERE ARE TIMES WHERE
BASICALLY I WASN'T SURE WHAT I
WAS GOING TO EAT THE GOOD THING
IS I'VE WORKED IN A RESTAURANT
SO. I WAS TAKING CARE OF THOSE
DAYS. HOWEVER I CAN TELL YOU
THAT- I BASICALLY ATE A LOT OF
CAMPBELL SOUP. AND I HAD
FRIENDS THAT- WOULD GIVE ME A
CUDDLE SWITCHER WOULD MIX WITH
MAYONNAISE AND PUT ON TOAST-
NON THAT AVOCADO TOAST AND I
WAS GOING FOR FIFTEEN DOLLARS A
PIECE. SO THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THAT WAS IMPORTANT AND IN THE
LAST COUPLE MONTHS I'VE BEEN
TALKING TO STUDENTS. AT
THROUGHOUT THE- CALIFORNIA BUT
SOME OF THEM- ARE LIVING IN A
LIVING IN THEIR POWER TO TWENTY
PUT THEMSELVES THROUGH SCHOOL
RIGHT NOW. THE ONE COMMON
DENOMINATOR WAS NOT ONE OF THEM
KNEW ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S. AND
THEY ALSO BOY WE CERTAINLY
COULD HAVE USED IT SO HERE WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET THE
EDUCATION UP TO THEM. AND
UTILIZE THESE RESOURCES THAT
ARE SITTING THERE. SO I MEMBERS
OF AB FIVE FORTY THREE IT'S
IMPORTANT BILL. THAT WOULD HELP
OUR COLLEGE STUDENTS AT A
MINIMAL COST BY OPENING THE
DOOR. SO THAT SO MANY MORE
BENEFITS THE STATE AND
RESIDENTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR ITEM ON THIS
BIPARTISAN. SUPPORT OF
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU- ASSEMBLY. A
DAVIS AT EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR.
ANY LEAD A WITNESSES SO FOUR OR
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. ANY
OPPOSITION. ANY TWO WINNERS.
OKAY- I HEAR NOTHING SO ABOUT
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS.
YEAH OKAY WE ARE MEMBER GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR AND-
APOLOGIES TO MY COLLEAGUES ON
THE BILLS I WANTED TO SPEAK ON
SEEM TO BE COMING UP EARLY
TODAY BUT I JUST WANTED TO
COMPLEMENT THE OFFER ON THIS I
THINK THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT
EFFORT- DRESSING BASIC NEEDS
INSECURITY PARTICULARLY FOOD
INSECURITY AMONG OUR COLLEGE
STUDENTS TO SUCH AN URGENT
PRIORITY FOR THE STATE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I CARE A LOT
ABOUT- IN MY DISTRICT AND
PRIVILEGE TO REPRESENT. CAL
STATE NORTHRIDGE WHICH OPENED
UP ITS SECOND FOOD BANK
RECENTLY THIS IS ONE SUCH A
PRESSING ISSUE UNFORTUNATELY
FOR SO MANY OF OUR STUDENTS
HERE I JUST WANT TO KNOW WE HAD
A BILL THAT WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW- TWO YEARS AGO THAT
REQUIRES- INFORMATION ABOUT
CALFRESH TO BE PLACED ON EVERY
STUDENTS PORTAL- SO EVERY TIME
THAT THEY SIGNED IN THEY CAN
GET INFORMATION ABOUT IT I
AGREE WITH YOU THAT ONE OF THE
MOST POWERFUL THINGS WE CAN DO.
IS DIRECT YOUNG PEOPLE TO- TO
THAT INFORMATION BUT- I THINK
IT'S A GREAT IDEA TO INCLUDED
IN THE ORIENTATION- I JUST
WANTED TO COMPLIMENT YOU THINK
REALLY WEREN'T BILL. BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY. GABRIEL OTHER. IF
NINE IS AN EMOTION. OKAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE SUPPORT
US US US IN SECOND BY- GABRIEL
MEMBER GABRIEL- CLOCKTOWER YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA CHOI HI CHOI I ARAMBULA
BERMAN BLOOM BLOOM HI GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN IRWIN HI KILEY
LEVINE. LEVINE I LOW. LOW I
SANTIAGO BALLADARES HELLO THERE
IS HI. THE VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO
IT'S OUT. THANK YOU THANK YOU I
DIDN'T I DIDN'T GIVE THAT
CHANCE TO MEMBERS OF THE
CLOSING STATEMENTS ABOUT.
ANYWAY YOU WOULD HAVE ASKED FOR
I'VE WORKED ON- SO REFER THAT
THE- ANY ANYWAY- I WOULD LIKE
TO. ASK I WILL COMMITTEE MEMBER
ASSEMBLY MONOPOLY ON ONCE AGAIN
TO COME TO THE- CHAIR POSITION
AND- JUST. PRESIDE FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE ITEMS THAT
BECAUSE SO I HAVE TO LEAVE
MYSELF. THANK YOU. THIS
AMERICAN BLOOM. MAY JUST CATCH
UP TO WHERE WE ARE NUMBER FIVE
NUMBER SIX SERVICE. NUMBER SIX
WHAT KIND OF FURNITURE. GRAYSON
HAS BEEN DONE. SIX SIX LOS.
THIS IS OUR CONSENT IS 9%
DISCOUNT ON OKAY THIS IS WHAT
OKAY. YOU'RE WELCOME. NEXT BILL
IN FILE ORDER IS AB SIX THIRTY
FIVE FILE ITEM EIGHT HI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVAN LOW.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLEASE PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHART AND
COLLEAGUES UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
DOES ENJOYED DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES I
ALSO ALLOW ME TO E BRIEF-
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY FIVE
HELPS TO ENSURE THAT WE SUPPORT
INNOVATIVE FINANCING OPTIONS
FOR IMPORTANT PROJECTS LIKE.
STUDENT AND FACULTY HOUSING AND
MODERNIZES THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATIONAL FACILITIES
AUTHORITY ACT WITH ME TODAY AND
SUPPORT TO HELP ELABORATE
FURTHER AND ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. H.
APPRECIATE THE- SUPPORT. AND
PRESENCE OF CALIFORNIA STATE
TREASURER FIONA MALL AS WELL AS
THE DIRECTOR OF THE EDUCATIONAL
FACILITIES AUTHORITY FRANK
MOORE I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
THE FIRST LEAD WITNESS IS IN
THE WITNESS VIDEO ROOM. FRANK
MOORE THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
FACILITIES AUTHORITY MR MORE
PLEASE PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. MISTER MORNING. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE CAN YOU HEAR
ME MISTER BLOOM YES OKAY THANK
YOU YES FRANK MOORE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATIONAL FINANCING
AUTHORITIES HERE WITH ME BUT I
JUST WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE OF
OPENING REMARKS AT NUMBER ONE-
AT THE STATE TREASURER I CHEER
THREE DIVISIONS I CASH
MANAGEMENT INVESTMENTS AND
PUBLIC FINANCE BUT I ALSO CHAIR
THIRTEEN ACTIVE BOARDS
COMMISSIONS AND AUTHORITIES AND
ONE OF THEM IS THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATIONAL FINANCING.
AUTHORITY FACILITIES AUTHORITY-
THIS- THIRTY WAS CREATED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX TO FINANCE
AND RE FINANCE THE EXPANSION OF
CONSTRUCTION OF EDUCATIONAL
FACILITIES LIKE LECTURE HALLS
LABORATORIES IN HOUSING
PROJECTS IT ALSO IS THIS POST
SECONDARY STUDENTS THE
FINANCING THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE TO THE COLLEGE
ACCESS TAX CREDIT FUND SO FOR
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS WE HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO FINANCE ANY
HOUSING PROJECTS STUDENT
HOUSING FOR TEACHER HOUSING. ON
UC'S CSU CAMPUSES OR
PARTICIPATING PRIVATE SECONDARY
EDUCATIONAL FACILITIES BECAUSE
WE HAVE THIS- REQUIREMENTS IN
THIS- IN THIS ACT THAT REQUIRES
A DEEP RESTRICTION OFF IF WE
ARE GOING TO- IF THE SCHOOL IS
GOING TO GREAT HOUSING ON OFF
CAMPUS SITES AND WE HAVE NOT
BEEN ALE TO FINANCE ONE
PROJECT IN TWENTY YEARS AND
THEREFORE WE CANNOT COMPETE
AGAINST THE J. P. A.'S POINT
POWER AUTHORITIES THAT ARE OUT
THERE THAT ARE FINANCING OF
THESE PROJECTS AN ACT. WAS
REALLY CREATED AND INTENDED SO
THAT THERE IS TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IF THE STATE IS
THE ONE THAT IS FINANCING OF
THESE PROJECTS RIGHT NOW IT IS
PRIVATELY FINANCED WE HAVE NO
SAY IN WHO- IS THE CONTRACTOR
WHO IS THE BUILDER- WHO IS THE
FINANCE ARE. AND EVERYTHING IS
IN THE DAY AND NOT CHANCE SO
THIS TECHNICAL WILL US TO
COMPETITIVE TO LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD AND ALLOW THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO FINANCE
STUDENT HOUSING AND TEACHER
HOUSING ON. ON ON PROPERTY THAT
IS NOT. ON THE COLLEGE CAMPUS
PER SE BUT OWNED BY THESE-
HIGHER EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
SO I'M JUST GONNA HAVE CRANKED
MORE THE SECOND DIRECTOR
EXPLAINED A LITTLE BIT MORE AND
WE'RE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
STATE TREASURER MA AND- I THANK
YOU FOR THROWING A CURVE AT ME
AND REVERSING THE ORDER OF THE
TESTIMONY. OF MR MORE PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU THANK YOU
TRIGGERED- I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE WITH THE TREASURER
SAID WE HAVE DISABILITY- AND
OUR CODE SECTION FOR TWENTY
YEARS IT'S NEVER BEEN USED.
YEAH I'VE NOTICED THAT YOU SEE
WAS USING OUR GPA COMPETITORS
TO DO THESE TYPES OF
TRANSACTIONS CONTACTED THEM TO
SEE WHY THEY WERE COMING
THROUGH US ANOTHER STATE
AGENCY. AND THE GERMAN IT WAS
BECAUSE OF THE GRANT DEED
RESTRICTIONS THAT WE HAVE IN
OUR CODE SECTION- SO THE BILL
AS PROPOSED WOULD ELIMINATE
THAT GRANTED RESTRICTION ON ALL
TYPES OF DISABILITIES-
OCCURRING. ON THE COLLEGE
CAMPUSES AND THOSE OCCURRING UP
COLLEGE CAMPUS BUT OWNED BY THE
UNIVERSITY WITH ONLY PERTAIN TO
THOSE TYPES OF. FINANCING
STRUCTURES THAT ARE OCCURRING
OFF CUT OFF CAMPUS AND NOT A
UNIVERSITY. WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS WILL- HELP- INSTITUTED
ANOTHER I THANK TO WILL THAT
COULD BE USED BY COLLEGES UC'S
CSU AND PRIVATE. NONPROFIT
COLLEGES TO HELP THEM. MEET
THEIR REQUIREMENTS FOR STUDENT
HOUSING. YEAH I CAN ANSWER
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT ARE THERE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT TO IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER. WORK IN THE GALLERY.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION OR WHO WISH TO
GIVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS ON. ON
ON THIS BILL WHO ARE IN THE
CHAMBER OR IN THE GALLERY AND
I'M SEEING NONE SO WE'LL MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. ON THE PHONE OR IN THE
QUEUE. MODERATOR YOU MISTER
JERRY IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL HIS PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHICH
THE FUTURE WE HAVE A LEAST ONE
PERSON TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLACE.
THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOW GO TO
LINE. FORTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING
THEN RAN FROM THE HOUSE OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITIES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. WHO WISH TO SPEAK.
NOW THIS IS A VERY OPPOSITION
PUBLIC COMMENT. AND FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THE NEW ZERO THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIR KNOWN AS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY-
COMMENTS- EITHER NEITHER OF FOR
AGAINST IS SIMPLY COMMENTS ON
THE BILL. FOR YOUR COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. NO
ONE HAS SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE DOES THE AUTHOR WAS TO
PROVIDE A CLOSING STATEMENT.
JUST EVERY ASPECT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RESEARCHER I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN OUR
CONSTITUTION OFFICER STATE
TREASURER FIONA MA FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO. THE DEDICATION TO
PHYSICALLY COME TO THE BUILDING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS I
JUST IS TESTAMENT TO HER
PASSION- ON THIS ISSUE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER- THE CHAIR
HAS SOME COMMENTS IN HIS NOTES
HERE ALL- READ THOSE AND I
AGREE WITH THEM THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD I
UNDERSTAND THAT LABOR MAY HAVE
SOME CONCERNS WITH THE BILL
PLEASE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM. FOR A POSSIBLE SOLUTION
TO A MUCH NEEDED. AND CREATIVE
WAY TO ALLOW CAMPUSES TO BEST
LEVERAGE LIMITED RESOURCES AND
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED HOUSING TO
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF. IS
THERE A MOTION. IS VALADARES
AND THE SECOND FROM MISS IRWIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LET'S HAVE
A ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL LOCAL YES
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA.
CHOI ARAMBULA BERMAN BLOOM HI
BLOOM HI GABRIEL. GABRIEL I
IRWIN. IRWIN I KILEY. LEVINE
LOW LOW I SANTIAGO CALAVERAS
HELLO THERE IS HI. THE VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO THE BILL IS ON CALL
HERE THIS BILL WILL REMAIN ON
CALL WITH A VOTE OF FIVE ZERO.
OUR NEXT BILL IS EIGHTY FIVE
SEVENTY SIX FILE ITEM NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN
MAIENSCHEIN. PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AS
PROPOSED IN THE ANALYSIS
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS THE
HIGHEST POPULATION OF MILITARY
PERSONNEL. SAN DIEGO IS
PROBABLY. ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACTIVE DUTY NAVY AND MARINE
CORPS SERVICE MEMBERS SERVICE
MEMBERS OFTEN TURN TO
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM TO PURSUE HIGHER
EDUCATION OR JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS. IN AN EFFORT TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO MILITARY
MEMBERS COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE
OFFERED COURSES HOSTED ON
MILITARY BASES HOWEVER IN
RECENT YEARS INCREASED SECURITY
SCREENING IS GREATLY REDUCED
ACCESS TO THESE CLASSES FOR
STUDENTS. NOT LIVING ON BASE
AND AS A RESULT MANY CLASSES
HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY CLOSED TO
THE PUBLIC. HIS CURRENT LAW
DOES NOT ALLOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO COLLECT
APPORTIONMENT FOR CLASSES THAT
ARE CLOSED TO THE PUBLIC THIS
IS EFFECTIVELY LIMITED THE
COURSE OFFERINGS AVAILABLE TO
SERVICE MEMBERS. AB FIVE SEVEN
SIX WOULD WAIVE THE OPEN COURSE
PROVISIONS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CLASSES PROVIDED TO
ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY PERSONNEL
ON MILITARY BASES. THIS WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS TO INCLUDE THE UNITS
OF FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENTS GRADUATED IN THOSE
CLASSES. FOR PURPOSES OF STATE
APPORTIONMENT THE BILL AIMS TO
ENSURE MILITARY SERVICE MEMBERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE COURSES.
THEY MAY NOT OTHERWISE BE ABLE
TO ACCESS DUE TO WORK SCHEDULES
FAMILY COMMITMENTS AND SERVICE
REQUIREMENTS. ALSO I HERE WITH
ME TO TESTIFY TELEPHONICALLY IN
SUPPORT OF MARK MCDONALD THE
SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THE LEAD WITNESS IS IN
THE WITNESS VIDEO ROOM. MISTER
MARK MCDONALD PRESIDENT OF MGI
ADVOCACY AND- THIS FOR MYSELF
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY WHENEVER YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU ARE CHAIRED
MEMBERS MARK MCDONALD ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND- FIRST I
DO WANT TO THANK THE STAFF FOR
THE EXCELLENT ANALYSIS AND
POINTING OUT- SOME SOME. ISSUES
THAT COULD MAKE THE BILL BETTER
AND THAT'S THAT WAS GREAT THANK
YOU- COMMUNITY COLLEGE COURSES
AS THE AUTHOR NOTED ARE
GENERALLY MUST BE OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
EXCEPTIONS THAT ARE MADE. AND
THAT IS IN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES AND ON HIGH SCHOOL
CAMPUSES THIS BILL WOULD ADD-
MILITARY BASES TO THOSE
EXCEPTIONS- THE EXCEPTIONS ARE
GENERALLY FOR PRIVACY OR SAFETY
OR SECURITY REASONS AND
MILITARY BASES ARE NO
DIFFERENT. THIS MEASURE WOULD
OPEN UP ACCESS TO MILITARY
PERSONNEL AND THEIR DEPENDENTS
AND HELP THEM MOVE- MORE
SWIFTLY INTO THE WORK FORCE-
ONCE THEY COMPLETE THEIR
COURSES SO REALLY APPRECIATE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND-
ASPIRIN I BOTH THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION OR WHO SIMPLY WHICH
TO GIVE COMMENTS. IN THE BACK
OF THE CHAMBER FLOOR OR IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE WILL MOVE
TO THE FLOOR TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU MISTER UP TO THOSE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK. IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THE ZERO
PRESS ONE ZERO. I BELIEVE WE
MAY HAVE ONE PERSON TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT. WE WILL NOW GO TO LINE.
FORTY FIVE. RIGHT NOT GOING ANY
ON WE HAVE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTED CALIFORNIA'S
SEVENTY THREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISHED
BIG THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IF YOUR WHAT IT DID
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND. ZERO KNOWING THE SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO ADD COMMENTS OF ANY.
TYPE. FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN
ZERO. THE TEACHER KNOWN AS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL.
BY COMPLEMENT THE AUTHOR I
THINK IT'S A GREAT MEASURE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU AND WILL
ACCEPT THAT AS A I REQUEST TO
SECOND THE MOTION AS WELL SO WE
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND AS THE
OFFER WAS TO PROVIDE A CLOSING
STATEMENT I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR INTRODUCING
THIS LEGISLATION AND ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE OUTLINED ON PAGE THREE OF
THE ANALYSIS. MUNITY COLLEGES
SHOULD NOT BE FINANCIALLY
PUNISHED FOR OFFERING CLASSES
AT MILITARY INSTALLATIONS THIS
BILL IS A COMMONSENSE SOLUTION.
AND A CHAIR MEDINA AND I ARE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT AB FIVE
SEVENTY SIX TODAY HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEDINA. CHOI ARAMBULA. BERMAN
BLOOM. GABRIEL I IRWIN IRWIN I
KILEY LEVINE LOW LOW I
SANTIAGO BALLADARES SO THERE IS
HI. THE VOTE IS FIVE ZERO BILLS
ON CALL. ALL RIGHT WE'LL HAVE
THAT BUILT ON ON CALL VOTERS
FOR FIVE ZERO AND WE WILL
PROCEED NOW TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB FOR TWENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRISTOPHER
WARD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLEASE
PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CAREER DEVELOPMENT COLLEGE
PREPARATORY- PREPARATION
COURSES ARE FREE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE COURSES THAT LEAD TO A
CERTIFICATE OR DEGREE.
CURRENTLY THESE COURSES SERVE
THE MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
OF OUR STUDENTS HOWEVER THERE
IS A FISCAL DISINCENTIVES FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO OFFER
THEM DUE TO THEIR FUNDING
STRUCTURE EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
ONE WHAT BETTER PEOPLE AS
FUNDING FOR NON CREDIT CAREER
DEVELOPMENT AND COLLEGE
PREPARATION COURSES THAT ARE
OFFERED WITH THE START AND END
DATE. BY AUTHORIZING THE
ATTENDANCE OF THOSE COURSES TO
BE TAKEN ACCORDING TO CENSUS
STATE RATHER THAN A POSITIVE
ATTENDANCE THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE COLLEGES WITH A
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO DEVELOP
AND OFFER THESE EFFECTIVE SHORT
TERM VOCATIONAL COURSES I'D
LIKE TO PRESENT MY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL CARLOS
CORTEZ. PRESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO
COLLEGE OF CAN. OF CONTINUING
EDUCATION. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
AND- MY- I BELIEVE- CARLOS
COURT. SO THE WITNESS IS. ON
THE LINE. MODERATOR. WE ARE
JUST A MOMENT THERE YOU ARE.
BUDGETARY COULD NOT APPEAR THAT
MR CORTEZ HAS CALLED IN FOR THE
CONFERENCE GOING KNOWN BY MR
CORTEZ IF HE'S CALLED IN AS THE
PARTICIPANTS. PRESS THEN ZERO
THIRST SO THAT WE MAY OPEN AS.
THE CASF DOES NOT APPEAR THAT
THE OF WHICH THIS PRESIDENT.
WELL WE'LL MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AND IF HE DOES ARRIVE
WITH MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
LET US KNOW. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. IN
OPPOSITION OR WHO WISH TO
ADDRESS COMMENTS OF ANY TYPE
WHO ARE IN THE CHAMBER OR IN
THE GALLERY. SEEING NONE
MODERATOR WOULD YOU LOOK TO SEE
IF THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE OR IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO MAKE COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. WE HAVE AT LEAST
ONE PERSON WHO SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT. WE WILL NOW GO TO LINE
FORTY SIX. EACH CHILD CARE AND
ASHLEY WALKER WITH NOTHING IN
ON BEHALF OF THE ECSTASY AS AND
CONTINUING EDUCATION AS WELL AS
NORTH KOREANS COUNTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. AND MOUNT SAN
ANTONIO COLLEGE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NO ONE ELSE IS SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK MODERATOR
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. FOR THOSE WHO WISH
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO NO ONE HAS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU AND- WOULD YOU
CHECK TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO SIMPLY
ADD COMMENTS REGARDING THE BILL.
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
SURE NO ONE IS SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE DOES THE AUTHOR WHICH
PROVIDE A CLOSING STATEMENT
THANK YOU MISTER CHIR THIS
BILL ENJOYS THE SUPPORT OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LIKE A
CALIFORNIA THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATIONS A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN THE
NUMBER OF OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE THE- IS THERE A
MOTION. AND A SECOND. ANYONE
INCLUDING THOSE HUDDLED ON THE
FLOOR. PERHAPS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL
PERHAPS- MR GABRIEL'S LIKE TO
CHIME IN. THANK YOU HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. THE MOTION
BEFORE US IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
ALL AS THE SECRETARY TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA. CHOI ARAMBULA
BERMAN. BLOOM HI BLOOM HI
GABRIEL. GABRIEL I IRWIN. IRWIN
I HIGHLY LEVINE LOW LOW HI
SANTIAGO CALAVERAS. BALLADARES
HI. THE VOTE IS FIVE ZERO THE
BILL IS ON CALL. THANK YOU THE
VOTE IS FIVE ZERO WILL HOLD
THAT BILL ON CALL OUR NEXT BILL
IS. CHAIR MEDINA'S BILL AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS HE IS ON HIS
WAY. NOW WE HAVE THE CHAIRS
BILL AND I ASK YOUR AND DEL.
THAT WE'VE WAITED FOR HIM TO BE
HERE SO THAT. GET THE RESPECT
THAT HE IS. TO AND IT'S GOOD TO
SEE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
WOULD LIKE TO BE HEARD. A
MODICUM OF PATIENTS AS REQUIRED
SOMETIMES. YEAH.
YES YOUR- BUT
THIS YEAR. YES YEAH. YES. OUR
NEXT BILL TODAY IS AB TWO
SEVENTY FIVE THAT IS FILE ITEM
ELEVEN BY OUR HAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA. SOME OF OUR-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER CHAIR
HAVE BEEN PATIENT AND WAITED
FOR YOU. THANK YOU GOOD TO HAVE
YOU BACK IN THE ROOM YOU MAY
PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
SIR THANK YOU MISTER BLUE.
TODAY I PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWO SEVENTY FIVE. AB TWO
SEVENTY FIVE WOULD REDUCE THE
MAXIMUM PROBATIONARY PERIOD FOR
ALL CLASSIFIED COMMUNITY
COLLEGE EMPLOYEES WORKING IN A
NON MERIT DISTRICTS FROM ONE
YEAR TO SIX MONTHS. FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY DAYS OF PAID
SERVICE WHICHEVER IS LONGER.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE MEMBERS
WORKING IN NON MERIT DISTRICTS
NEED PARITY WITH THOSE OF THEIR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE MARRIAGE
DISTRICT COUNTERPARTS. IN NON
MERIT DISTRICTS CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES HAVE A PROBATIONARY
PERIOD MAXIMUM OF ONE YEAR. BUT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES WORKING IN MERRITT
DISTRICTS ONLY HAVE A
PROBATIONARY PERIOD MAXIMUM OF
SIX MONTHS. THE PRIMARY PURPOSE
OF PROBATIONARY PERIODS FOR
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES IS
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE
EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE TO PERFORM
THE DUTIES OF THEIR POSITION.
TO THE SATISFACTION OF THE
EMPLOYER BEFORE GAINING MY
PERMANENT STATUS INCLUDING DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS. IF REPORTER
PERFORMANCE EVALUATION PROCESS
IS PROPERLY UTILIZE. A SIX
MONTH PROBATIONARY PERIOD
PROVIDES MORE THAN ENOUGH TIME
FOR MANAGEMENT TO DETERMINE
WHETHER AN EMPLOYEE HAS MET.
THE STANDARDS. BRINGING PARITY
TO THE NON MERIT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS WILL NOT
COMPROMISE THE QUALITY OF THE
WORK PERFORMED. TWO YEARS AGO
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE. THE
REDUCE THE PROBATIONARY PERIOD
FOR K. TWELVE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES WORKING IN NON MERIT
DISTRICTS FROM ONE YEAR TO SIX
MONTHS. IN ALIGNMENT WITH K.
TWELVE CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
WORKING IN AMERICA DISTRICTS.
INADVERTENTLY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES WORKING IN
NON MERIT DISTRICTS WERE LEFT
OUT. AB TWO SEVENTY FIVE THIS
COSPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
AFL-CIO. HERE TO TESTIFY IS MR
LORE WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND LIBBY
SANCHEZ WITH SEIU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. YES IS THAT-
BECAUSE THE ONLY LOWER OUR
WITNESS. YES THANK YOU PLEASE
CHECK THE NUMBER FIFTY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS THIS
IS TOM WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL INCLUDES ASSOCIATION WE
ARE THE FOUNDERS OF. EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTY FIVE EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY
FIVE IF THEY CLEAN UP BILLS
THAT PROVIDE PARITY FOR OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CRESSMAN
PLEASE WHO WORK IN NON A
DISTRICT. YOU MIGHT HEAR THE
OPPOSITE STATE THAT SIX MONTH
IS IN TIME TO EVALUATE. WELL WE
DID. IT MONTHS FISHING INTO
PACKAGE. IT SIX IF THE PATIENT
COLLEGE GET J. CAN YOU COLLEGE
AMERICAN. THEN WHY INTO CORTES.
OF CLEAN PUBLIC CLOUD I NEED
FOR. WHAT IS IT ABOUT THE OF.
WE DON'T ALREADY HAVE IT IS
BECAUSE THEY WERE IN A PART
LEFT OUT OF THE CAR BILL YEARS
AGO. I HAVE FOR YOUR ID FOR TO
CORRECT OKAY IN. PEOPLE KEEN
COLLEGE RIGHT. NOT MAKE IT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR. THEY YOU
MISS LEVINE THIS LEAD WITNESS
IN SUPPORT CALLING IS LIBBY.
COVER RELATES AT. FOR THIS
EMPLOYEES IN. UNION MS SANCHEZ
WHENEVER YOU READY. GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER LOOK BE
STAYING CALDERON BE HAPPY THAT
THE I YOU HELLO. REP CLASSES
AND COMMUNITY BECAUSE AND K.
TWELVE SCHOOL. OF MEDICINE BY
MY AB SEVENTY FIVE OF REALLY
ABOUT OUT ALREADY NEARLY SIX TO
ENSURE THE SIMILAR THE WORKERS
SOME WORK HAVE THE SAME PER DAY.
PERIOD THAT IT MATTER IF YOU'RE
AMERICA SCHOOL AND PART OF TOWN
OR NON WILL ANOTHER PART OF
TOWN YOUR TO PROCESS AND TO
PERMANENT C. R. SAME. OCCUPIED
STAFF PRIOR TO THE END OF THEIR
PROBATIONARY PERIOD BECAUSE
THAT SIMPLY HAVE NOT BEEN THE
EXPERIENCE IN K. TWELVE NON
MERIT SCHOOL WARREN MERIT
SYSTEM COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHERE
THE PROBATIONARY PERIOD THIS
BILL SEEKS TO ESTABLISH IS
ALREADY THE ROLE. AS IT RELATES
TO COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
SOMETIMES THE INTEREST OF
PUBLIC POLICY NECESSITATES
LEGISLATIVE INTERVENTION TO
ENSURE. PLAYING FIELD OF THE
LEVEL ONE AND THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE TIME FINALLY HIRING AND
TRAINING PROCESS EATEN
PROTOCOLS WORK WHILE TO ENSURE
A QUALIFIED CANDIDATE. ARE
COLLECTED AND READY TO HIT THE
GROUND RUNNING A PERMANENT
HIRES AT THE END OF THEIR
PROBATIONARY PERIOD. AND NO
WORK JUST AS WELL AS NON MERIT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES UNDER AB TWO
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MS SANCHEZ. MODERATOR THE
LEAD WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
SHOULD BE ON THE LINE RYAN
MACKEL HANEY THE POLICY AND
ADVOCACY MANAGER FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA MISTER MICHAEL MAYBE
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY. SURE WE
SPEAKER- WITNESS IS IN FACT A
LOG IN FOR THE CALL. IT APPEARS
THERE ARE NONE- RESPONDING
LEVINE IS OPEN. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL THEN MOVE TO PBLIC
COMMENT TO A MODERATOR IF. YOU
BECOME AWARE THAT MR MACKEL
HANEY- IS AVAILABLE TO ADD
COMMENTS PLEASE LET ME KNOW.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER FLOOR IN THE GALLERY
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OR WHO
SIMPLY WISH TO ADD COMMENTS ON
THIS ITEM WHO ARE HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. OR IN THE GALLERY
SEEING NONE WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES. MODERATOR THERE
ANY WITNESS ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE. FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK UP IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO TO LINE. FIFTY TWO.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE A LOT OF
THE SHARE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU MODERATOR WOULD YOU LET US
KNOW IF THERE ARE ANY-
WITNESSES WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS. ONE
ZERO. HAVE AT LEAST ONE PHONE
LINE TO THE SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK ONE MOMENT PLACE.
AT THE MOMENT THANKS. WE WILL
NOW GO TO LINE. FIFTY THREE.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS RYAN MAC
MINI WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA- CAN
PEOPLE HEAR ME. WE CAN PLEASE
PROCEED WE WERE EXPECTING YOU A
LITTLE EARLIER BUT- HAPPY TO
HEAR YOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. GREAT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INDULGENCES
INDULGENCES I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
TECHNICAL ISSUES WE ARE
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO AB AB
TWO SEVEN FIVE- WE'RE CONCERNED
THAT BY REDUCING THE LENGTH OF
TIME TO CALL JUST TO. TALK
ABOUT IT PLEASE CALL IT WILL
NOT HAVE THE LENGTH OF TIME
NECESSARY TO PARTLY ABOUT HIS.
IDEA WITH THAT ABILITY UNDER
CURRENT LAW COLLEGES HAVE A TWO
YEAR TO DO THIS PROCESS TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CREDIT
ADDITIONAL PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR MENTORSHIP. TO
THOSE IN NEED. BY CUTTING
EXPERIENCE TIME AND HALF IT
WILL AMOUNT OF TIME THE CALL TO
GET THE VITAL I. SO WE BELIEVE
THAT THERE ARE ONLY TWO AND
UNDER CAR COUPONS THE THIS BILL.
FIRST IT COULD HURT THE SUCCESS
OF OUR STUDENTS COMMITTING AN
EMPLOYEE WHO NOT BE APPROPRIATE
FOR THE WORLD- TO BECOME FOR.
THE ECOLOGY TO NOT HAVE ENOUGH
TIME TO COOLEY EVALUATE EACH
AND SECONDLY COULD INCENTIVIZE
COLLEGE SELECT OMAR. POLICE WHO
HAVE BEEN A FROM THAT
ADDITIONAL MONTHS. TO TRY ON
THE. AND THEN FINALLY I HAD
LIKE IT'S ABOUT THIS.
DIFFERENCES IN A- PROCESS IS
BETWEEN. MERIT AND ALL MERIT
THAT. AROUND FIVE OR SO
DISTRICTS ON THE- PRE HIRING.
THEY REQUIRE APPLICANTS TO TAKE
EXAM TESTING PER APTITUDE FOR
THE JOB. HM APPLICANTS. IT IS
DO NOT NEED A LONG TO. ABOUT
YOU KNOW. YEAH SIXTY EIGHT
DISTRICTS DO NOT THIS PROBLEM.
AND THAT'S THE ADDITIONAL MY TO
HAVE. AND PROVIDE BUT WITH ALL
THE TO THEIR NEW CLASS THE
POLICE. SO THANK YOU TIME AGAIN
I. FOR THE TECHNICAL TO- AND
I'D BE HAPPY AND ANY. THANK YOU
I MAY HAVE MISSED IT- BUT FOR
THE RECORD YOU ARE REPRESENTING.
WELL I APOLOGIZE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE THE NONPROFIT TRADE
ASSOCIATION THAT REPRESENTS
CALIFORNIA'S SEVENTY THREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
THANK YOU OUR RECORD IS
COMPLETE AND- MODERATOR WOULD
YOU CHECK TO SEE IF THERE ARE
ANY WITNESSES ADDITIONAL
WISHING WITNESSES. FOR AGAINST
OR JUST WISHING TO ADD COMMENTS.
FOR YOUR COMMENT PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO. YEAH WHEN THE SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU DOES THE AUTHOR WAS
TO PROVIDE A CLOSING STATEMENT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THAT'LL DO. WE HAVE A
MOTION WAS THEIR SECOND. THANK
YOU WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THE MOTION BEFORE US IS
DO PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR MEDINA HI MEDINA
HI CHOI. ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I
BERMAN BLOOM HI BLOOM HI
GABRIEL GABRIEL I IRWIN. IRWIN
I HIGHLY LEVINE. LOW LOW HI
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI CALAVERAS.
NOW THERE'S NOT VOTING. THE
VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO IN FACT.
CONGRATULATIONS MISTER CHAIR
THE VOTERS SEVEN ZERO OF THE-
BILL IS OUCH. AND OUR NEXT BILL
TODAY IS- ANOTHER BUILT BY
MISTER CHAIR. THAT IS EIGHTY
THREE SEVENTY FIVE FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN PLEASE PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TODAY
PRESENT AB THREE SEVENTY FIVE.
A REINTRODUCTION OF AB EIGHT
NINETY SEVEN WHICH HAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND WAS HELD
DUE TO CLOSE IN NINETEEN. AB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE WOULD CHANGE
THE PERCENTAGE OF OUR A PART
TIME TEMPORARY EMPLOYEE MAY
TEACH UP 285% OF THE HOURS PER
WEEK OF A FULL TIME EMPLOYEE
HAVING COMPARABLE DUTIES. UNDER
THE 67% THRESHOLD MANY FACULTY
MEMBERS THE TEACHING MULTIPLE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AT THE SAME TIME PIECE
TOGETHER A FULL TIME SCHEDULE.
THESE ARE THE SO CALLED FREEWAY
FLYERS. IT LIMITS THEIR ABILITY
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE CAMPUS
COMMUNITY AND BE A RESOURCE TO
OTHERS TO STUDENTS. THE BILL
WILL HELP IMPROVE STUDENT
SUCCESS AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVEL WELL I DRESSING
ONE OF THE SIGNIFICANT
HARDSHIPS FACED BY PART TIME
FACULTY MEMBERS. AB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE IS CO SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE INDEPENDENCE
AND THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
HERE TO TESTIFY IS JIM MAILERS
PRESIDENT OF C. S. T. COMMUNITY
COLLEGE COUNCIL DR FRANCIS HOW
OUR LIBRARIAN AT LANEY COLLEGE.
THANK YOU- THAT'S NOT WHO I
HAVE LISTED- BUT- DO WE HAVE
WITNESSED IN. IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL HAS PREPARED TO SPEAK AT
THIS TIME. YES JIM MILLER. IS
PRESENT. I THANK YOU THANK YOU
WOULD YOU IDENTIFY HERE THAT
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS CORRECT.
BACK TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
COUNCIL OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS CORRECT.
GREAT THANK YOU AND PLEASE
REMEMBER WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THIS
VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AT THE CHAIR
MENTIONED THIS BILL WAS
INTRODUCED LAST YEAR BUT
BECAUSE OF COBEQUID HELD OFF-
FROM GOING OVER THE SENATE
SIDE- THE CHAIR HIT ALL OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS THAT I WAS GOING TO
HIT BUT JUST. TO MAKE THE LONG
STORY SHORT WE HAVE MANY PART
TIME FACULTY THAT HAVE TO
TRAVEL FROM DISTRICT TO
DISTRICT JUST TO BE ABLE TO
PIECE TOGETHER A FULL TIME
LOAD. THIS WOULD ENABLE THEM TO
TEACH A GREATER PERCENTAGE OF
ASSIGNMENT WITHIN ONE DISTRICT
WITHOUT HAVING TO TRAVEL AS
MUCH. THAT WILL LEAD TO A MORE
STABLE EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT
FOR STUDENTS BECAUSE WILL HAVE
LESS PERSONNEL. DRIVING TO
DIFFERENT PLACES WILL HAVE
FEWER FACULTY TEACHING HIGHER
LOADS IN EACH INDIVIDUAL
DISTRICT WHICH WILL LEAD TO-
YOU KNOW MORE OF A STABLE
ENVIRONMENT STUDENTS AND- MORE
JOB SECURITY FOR PART TIME
FACULTY WON'T HAVE TO FEEL LIKE
THEY HAVE TO PIECE TOGETHER SO
MANY DIFFERENT JOBS SO. LAST
YEAR THIS PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
SEVENTY SIX ZERO WE'RE SHOOTING
FOR EIGHTY TO ZERO THIS YEAR SO
WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER MILLER.
MODERATOR THE SECOND LEADING
WITH LEAD WITNESS- CALLING AND
AS FRANCIS HOWARD WITH THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION. OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND MISTER HOWARD. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY
NAME IS PRESS THE POWER AND I
AM A PART TIME LIBRARIAN AT
LANEY COLLEGE. I AM ASKING FOR
THE PASSAGE OF AB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE WHICH WOULD ALLOW PART
TIME FACULTY TO TEACH MORE
CLASSES UP 285% OF THE FOR LOW.
TIME NO. DETAIL WITH GRANTS
GREATER ACCESS TO THEIR
INSTRUCTORS WHO WILL HAVE THE
TIME TO MEET WHICH TO THE
OUTSIDE OF THE CLASSROOM. FOUR
ONE TWO ONE AT BY. YEAH OF
KNOWLEDGE BUYERS. IS NOT DEPEND
ON TIME BACK IN CLASSROOM. GO
TIME BUT THE FACT THAT G. DOES
MAKE A DIFFERENCE. YES THERE
WILL ALLOW ME TO UPLOAD TIME
JUST TO THE OF ONE ON ONE AND
BUY. MAKERS AND DURING IN
ADDITION TO INCREASING STUDENT
SUCCESS PART TIME FACULTY WILL
HAVE LORD JOHN JUST SERVE OUR
SHARE GOVERNANCE COMMITTEES
RANGING FROM THE ACADEMIC
SENATE. THE BUDGET CURRICULUM
AND ACCREDITATION COMMITTEE.
JEFF BRIDGES TO PAY. GIVE PART
TIME YOU ARE. ACTOR THEIR
CAMPUS BLACK APRIL CHáVEZ
EXCELLENCE THE ACADEMIC
INTEGRITY OF OUR ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS AND COURSES. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR EFFORTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WILL NOW MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION OR WHO WISH TO ADD
COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM WHO ARE
ON THE FLOOR OR IN THE GALLERY.
SEEING NONE. WE WILL MOVE ON TO
THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU CHECKS. FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. PRESS ONE MIN ZERO. WE
WILL NOW GO TO LINE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. STEPHANIE
GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATIONOF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
PRACTICE SPONSORED. THANK YOU.
NOW GO. TO ONE FIFTY SIX.
MEMBERS DAVID HOPKINS WITH A
CALIFORNIA ECOLOGY DEPENDENCE-
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE KENTUCKY.
LINE. FIFTY NINE. BUT AFTERNOON
MY NAME ALREADY READ MANY FIRST
THERE AND I TEACH AT AMERICAN
RIVER COLLEGE I ALSO REPRESENT
A FACULTY UNION- AT AMERICAN
RIVER COLLEGE I AM HERE TO
SUPPORT AB THREE SEVENTY FIVE.
STRONG SUPPORT IN FACT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK THANK YOU MODERATOR
WOULD YOU CHECK TO SEE IF THERE
ARE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
EITHER- ON THE PHONE OR IN THE
CASE. TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO THIS
TIME PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO SURE
NO ONE IS SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO STATE THANK YOU WOULD
YOU CHECK TO SEE IF THERE ARE
ANY ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO ADD COMMENTS OF
ANY KIND. ON THIS BILL. PLEASE
TELL ME THE FINAL CALL FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO COMMENT ON
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND NO ONE
IS SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THE MOTION AND A
SECOND DOES THE AUTHOR WISH TO
PROVIDE A CLOSING STRICTLY
ASKED FOR AND I WILL. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND ON THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OKAY THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA ALL RIGHT. MEDINA HI
CHOI. ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA HI
BERMAN BLOOM HI BLOOM I'D
GABRIEL. GABRIEL I IRWIN IRWIN
HI KILEY LEVINE. LOW LOW I
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO HI CALAVERAS
BALLOT THERE IS I. THE VOTE
EIGHT ZERO IT'S OUT. THE VOTERS.
SEVEN ZERO EIGHT ZERO EIGHT
ZERO. MOVED UP FROM THE LAST
ONE. AND THAT BILL IS NOW
CONGRATULATIONS MISTER CHAIR.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
FINAL BILL. OF THE MORNING THAT
IS AB FIVE NINETY FIVE FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN AGAIN BY CHAIR
MEDINA. THANK YOU A MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF AB FIVE NINETY FIVE AND ALSO
FOR YOUR PATIENCE HERE THIS
MORNING. AB NINETY FIVE WOULD
ENSURE THE DECISIONS ABOUT NEW
ADMISSIONS PROPOSALS ARE MORE
TRANSPARENT. HAVE PROPER
OVERSIZED AND IMPACT
ASSESSMENTS AND COORDINATE
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS THE PUBLIC
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY
EDUCATION SYSTEM. C. ISSUES
CURRENTLY CONSIDERING THE
ADDITION OF A NEW ADMISSION
POLICY THE PROPOSAL WOULD ADD
ONE YEAR QUANTITATIVE REASONING
COURSE WORK THROUGH THE AG
SEVEN MISSION REQUIREMENTS
RAISING THE REQUIREMENT FROM
FIFTY YEARS FIFTEEN YEARS OF
COMPREHENSIVE COLLEGE
PREPARATORY COURSEWORK TO
SIXTEEN YEARS FOR THE ENTRY
IMPRESSMENT CLASS. OF TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN. THE ADDITIONAL
YEAR QUALITATIVE REASONING AS
AN ADMISSIONS REQUIREMENTS.
COULD EXACERBATE THE VERY SAME
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT GAP THAT
THE STATE IS WORKING HARD TO
OVERCOME STUDENTS AND LOW
INCOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS ALREADY
LACK ACCESS TO MANY COURSES
THAT ARE OFFERED AT A FLUENT
SCHOOLS. ADDING THIS
REQUIREMENT WITHOUT PROPER
IMPACT ASSESSMENTS A PRE AND
POST CLOVEN GAPS OR THE TEACHER
SHORTAGE WILL AGAIN EXACERBATE
EXISTING INEQUITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. OCTOBER. TWENTY
NINETEEN THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE HOSTED AN
OVERSIGHT HEARING REGARDING THE
RATIONALE BEHIND THE NEW
PROPOSAL POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND REACTIONS FROM
THE STAKEHOLDER GROUPS SINCE
THEN THE CSU HAS AT HERE TO THE
LEGISLATURE'S REQUEST OF
CREATING THE TASK FORCE BUT THE
WORK OF THE TASK FORCE IN THE
INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS DOES NOT
RELIEVE TRANSPARENCY OR EQUITY
CONCERNS RESPONSE TO THIS AB
FIVE NINETY FIVE WELL
ESTABLISHED GUIDELINES AS A
SEGMENTS REVISIT THEIR MISSION
REQUIREMENTS. THE BILL WILL
STREAMLINE TO CREATE MORE
TRANSPARENCY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEMS TO PROMOTE FAIRNESS FOR
ALL THE STUDENTS AND FOUR KEY
WAYS ONE COLLABORATION WITH
EDUCATION ENTITIES THAT WOULD
BE IMPACTED BY POLICY CHANGES
TO AN INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTY
STUDY ON THE POTENTIAL IMPACT
THE POLICY CHANGE WOULD HAVE ON
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF COLOR
THREE PRESENTATION OF POLICY
CHANGES TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
COMMITTEE TO OVERSEE A MULTI
YEAR PLAN. TO THE POLICY CHANGE
PASSED THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES OR UC REGENTS AB FIVE
NINETY FIVE WOULD PROMOTE
TRANSPARENCY AND FAIRNESS IN
OUR UNIVERSITY ADMISSIONS
PROCESS AT A TIME WHEN THE PATH
TO COLLEGE. REMAINS UNEQUAL- TO
TEST ANSWER. IS MANY RODRIGUEZ
FROM EDUCATION TRUST WEST AND
ME SO SECURE THOSE FROM THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MISTER RODRIGUEZ WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
NUMBER NINE IS MANUAL TO GET
SHALL WE HAVE THE EDUCATION
TRUST WHAT WE ARE A RESTRICTION
OF THE NONPROFIT WORKING TO-
EXPLODES EXPLODED AND CLOSE
OPPORTUNITIES CHECK OUT. BOB
FOR LANCASTER JOINT CULTURE-
FIRST LIKE TO SPEAK TO SOMEONE
IN THE- LEADER'S AND COMMITMENT
EDUCATION ACCIDENT TRANSPARENCY.
AUTHOR OFF BY SAYING THAT THE
PRINCIPLE EMBEDDED IN THIS BILL-
SEVENTY TRANSPARENCY
COORDINATION AND EQUITY MUST
AUTHENTICALLY INCLUDE OUR K.
TWELVE SYSTEM AND STUDENTS. AND
STAKEHOLDERS WILL BE HEAVILY
IMPACTED BY ANY UNDERGRADUATE
ELIGIBILITY CHANGE. WHEN
ANALYZING FUTURE ELIGIBILITY
CHANGE AND OUTLINED BY THIS
BILL WE MUST ENSURE WE ARE
FOCUSING ON THE DISPARATE
IMPACT TO KEY STUDENT GROUPS
SHE REGION AS WELL AS A WHOLE
SENIOR CLASS NOT JUST THOSE WHO
ARE ALREADY ON TRACK TOWARDS
COLLEGE. FURTHERMORE
ORGANIZATIONS WHOSE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR STATE ON THE CURRENT
IMPLEMENTATION COMMITTEE FOR
DEAN QUANTITATIVELY IN PROPOSAL
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT-
SEVENTEEN TRANSPARENCY IN
EQUITY ALSO CARRY OVER TO THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE. OUR
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN ONE WHERE
KEY QUESTIONS HAVEN'T BEEN
ADDRESSED A DETAILED
DESCRIPTION OF THE RESEARCH
CALL FOR THE STARTING WHAT THEN
SHARED PUBLICLY UNTIL VERY
RECENTLY AND OVERALL
COMMUNICATION WITH COMMITTEE
ALWAYS CASE EQUAL PARTNERS
DOESN'T SEEM TO REFLECT THE
INTENTION OF THIS TWO YEAR
PROCESS AND COULD UNDERMINE THE
COULD BE PAYING THE COMMUNITY
HAD. PLACED IN THIS PROCESS. WE
NEED TO LEARN FOR PASSAGE. AND
SHE THAT. PROPOSED CAN'T BE
ADVANCED WITHOUT TO LIFT OR
MEANINGFUL FROM COLE BETWEEN
STATE. AND WITHOUT FRONT AND
CLEAR DISPLAY IMPACT NOT. WHICH
WE TO CENTER ACTUALLY PARTY
DISCUSS THAT DIRECTLY IMPACTED
UNDER AND- COMMUNITIES. AND IT
HAS ONLY BEEN MAGNIFIED BY THE
PANDEMIC WE'RE ALL GOING TO DO
AND THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT
WERE LIVING THERE TODAY BUT
PEOPLE ARE DEMANDING A SEAT AT
THE TABLE. AND INTENTIONAL
CONSIDERATION BY POLICY MAKERS
WANT HEALTH SYSTEMS. ARE ARE
NOT THAT. AB FIVE FIVE YEAH
SURE THAT ANY FUTURE CHANGE THE
DOCTOR THERE JUST WITH ACT
ACCESS FIRST. AND ESTABLISHES A
CARD. SO MANY STAY HAVE BEEN
TO- IN THE PAST IT BACK TO ****
I. THANK YOU THIS LEADING.
CALLING AS MUCH SO. PRESIDENT
OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. SECURUS. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN THE NINE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M MICHELLE
SPEAKING OKAY PRESIDENT TRUMP
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY A STATEWIDE POLICY
RESEARCH AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
MAKING SURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND. AND
SUCCEED IN COLLEGE WITH A VERY
EXPLICIT FOCUS ON CLOSING
RACIAL ETHNIC GAPS IN COLLEGE
PREPARATION COLLEGE GOING AND
COLLEGE SUCCESS THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN ENOUGH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND COMMITMENT TO
THIS ISSUE. AS YOU ALL KNOW THE
PANDEMIC HAS RAISED SERIOUS
CHALLENGES ACROSS OUR STATE AND
NATION ESPECIALLY FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS AND K.
TWELVE AND COLLEGE. AS WE THE
DOUBLE. A CO NINETY AT RACES.
WE KNOW ONE THING CONTINUE TO
BE. CALLING APERTURE IS A KEY
NOT PERFECT. ECONOMIC STRENGTH
NOT JUST FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
EARN A DEGREE BUT REALLY AS AN
INOCULATION AGAINST UNEQUAL.
IMPACT OF JOB LOSS. THAT'S WHAT
TO ADMISSION REQUIREMENTS ARE
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES ARE
SIGNIFICANT AND MORE IN YOUR
ENGAGEMENT. EIGHTY FIVE NINE
FIVE RECOGNIZES THIS AND WOULD
PROVIDE THE STATE AND STUDENTS.
WITH A MORE THOUGHTFUL FAIR AND
TRANSPARENT PROCESS THE STATE
HAS AN INTEREST IN ENSURING
THAT EACH SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION. RESULT IN A FAIR AND
EQUITABLE ADMISSIONS PROCESS
FOR THE STUDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
THE PUBLIC ALSO DEMAND FISH.
AND DEMAND THAT HIGHER
EDUCATION AND K. TWELVE SCHOOLS
WORK TOGETHER WE HAVE A COMMON
GOAL WITH CHER MEDINA AND
SUPPORT THIS BILL IT IS
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO OUR PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES NOT SHIFT
INSTITUTIONAL INTEREST.
POLICIES THAT IMPACT THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ABILITY
TO PURSUE THEIR COLLEGE DREAMS
IN THE STATE SHOULD NOT BE
MADE. WITHIN THE CONFINES OF
FULL CONSIDERATION OF HOW THE
UNIVERSITY ARRIVED AT THAT
DECISION. WHAT OTHER OPTIONS
WERE CONSIDERED. AND WHAT IS
THE POTENTIAL IMPACT OF THE
CHANGE IN THAT MISSION.
ESPECIALLY IN A COPA NINETEEN
ENVIRONMENT MOST IMPORTANTLY WE
MUST ENSURE THAT ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS DO NOT
SYSTEMICALLY LEAVE BEHIND BLACK
FLAG NEXT NATIVE AMERICAN AND
SOUTHEAST ASIAN STUDENTS. WE
MUST ENSURE THAT STUDENTS ARE
NOT EXCLUDED FROM OUR
UNIVERSITIES BASED ON WHERE
THEY GO TO HIGH SCHOOL AND WHAT
COURSES THOSE HIGH SCHOOLS
CHOOSE TO OFFER THEM. WE MUST
MAKE SURE THEY'RE NOT EXCLUDED
BASED ON WHERE THEY LIVE OR HOW
WEALTHY THEY ARE. EIGHTY FIVE
NINETY FIVE ESTABLISHES A CLEAR
CRITERIA FOR HOW THE CSU AND UC
CONSIDER ADOPT AND IMPLEMENT
NEW ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS.
AND MOVE US CLOSER TO ENSURING
THAT KIND OF DILIGENCE WE
DESERVE. ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR IDOL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OR
WANTING TO ADD COMMENTS OF ANY
TYPE ON THIS BILL WHO ARE IN
THE BACK OF THE GALLERY- IN THE
GALLERY OR IN THE- BACK OF THE
CHAMBER. SEEING NONE GROUND
CONTROL THE MODERATOR TOM ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE.
SORRY YOU GAVE ME THE GAVEL
THANK. THANK THANK YOU FOR THE
FUTURE FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WISH TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS. ONE NINE ZERO. WE
HAVE AT LEAST ONE PERSON TO
TAKE NOTE THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK ONE MOMENT. JUST A MOMENT.
BILL NOW GO TO BIND FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEDINA THIS
IS JOSH LEWIS WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION HERE
CALLING TO OFFER SUPPORT WE
KNOW THIS ISN'T AN ISSUE THAT'S
ARISEN AT UC RECENTLY BUT- WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE WITH.
THANK YOU. NO ONE L. TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH O SPEAK THANK
YOU- WILL YOU CHECK TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN. ZERO NO ONE IS SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU AND- FINALLY CAN YOU SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO ADD ANY OTHER COMMENTS-
OF ANY SORT ON THE BILL. IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT ON THE BILL.
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. THE
FUTURE KNOWN AS SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. DOES THE
AUTHOR WAS TO. PROVIDE A
CLOSING STATEMENT RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. WE HAVE A
QUESTION FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIVING OR COME. MORE A COMMENT
TEN EIGHT AND EXTENSION REALLY
OF THE CONVERSATION THAT I
THINK THAT THE CSU BEGAN A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO AND THAT
SOME OF OUR MID MEDINA BROUGHT
TO THE LEGISLATURE TO TALK
ABOUT HOW WE MAKE SURE THAT
HIGHER EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA
IS A PLACE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
I REALLY RESPECTED THAT THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT. TO DO THAT- IN
THE CONVERSATION THAT WE ALL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE AYE
I'VE VOTED NO ON ON THE BILL
PRIOR AND I WILL VOTE NO TODAY.
NOT BECAUSE I DISAGREE WITH THE
AUTHORS- INTENT- AND THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE HAVING
A PIECE OF RICH AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION TO HAVE. BUT
BECAUSE I DO YOU BELIEVE IN ONE
OF THE ARGUMENTS ARE AN
ARGUMENT THERE AND THAT THE CSU
IS ACKNOWLEDGING IN IN
CALIFORNIA THAT. COLLEGE
STUDENTS ARE WOEFULLY IN ACTIN
INADEQUATELY PREPARED. TO DO
COLLEGE LEVEL WORK IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT THEY ARE
SEEKING TO- IN IN- INDUCE. ARE
SECONDARY SCHOOLS TO- TO BETTER
PREPARE THEM BETTER EDUCATE
STUDENTS SO THAT THEY CAN DO
COLLEGE LEVEL WORK IN AND I
APPLAUD THE CSU AND THEIR
CHANGES TO THE REMEDIATION
PROGRAM WHICH WHEN I WAS CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION REMEMBER TALKING
ABOUT IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES
ABOUT HOW THIS IS A BAR TO
GRADUATION. THAT THAT THERE ARE
OTHER WAYS TO HELP STUDENTS DO
COLLEGE LEVEL WORK IN THERE AND
I WANT TO ENCOURAGE THAT TYPE
OF THINKING AT THE CSU BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO CHALLENGE OUR HIGH
SCHOOLS. TO DO- MUCH MORE AT TO
PREPARE CHILDREN FOR IT PREPARE
STUDENTS. FOR THE CRITICAL
THINKING THAT MUST OCCUR- IN
READING THE MOST CURRENT AT THE
COLLEGE LEVEL SO THAT WE CAN
HAVE. A STUDENTS IN- PREPARED
AS THEY GRADUATE FOR THE JOBS
OF THE FUTURE IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMENT- CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO. WRAP IT UP YEAH I JUST- TO
MY COLLEAGUE I WOULD SAY IS. I
DON'T DISAGREE- THE NEED FOR
STUDENTS TO BE PREPARED TO DO
COLLEGE WORK I THINK THE INTENT
OF THE BILL. IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY WORK WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS SO AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR- VOTE.
THANK YOU THE MOTION BEFORE US
IS TO PASS IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
I'M PRETTY SURE I HEARD A-
MULTI- A MOTION AND A SECOND
WAS THAT- MYSTERY. LOW WHO MADE
THE MOTION AND THE SECOND WAS
DOCTOR ARAMBULA. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA HI CHOI NINE CHOI HI
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA HI BERMAN
BLOOM HI BLOOM HI GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN- WHEN I KILEY
KILEY I. LEVINE LEVINE NOW LOW
LOW I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
BALLADARES BALLOT THERE IS AYE
VOTES ELEVEN ONE THE BILL IS
ALEX VOTERS ELEVEN WHEN YOUR
BILL IS OUT AND TO. I WILL NOW
MERCIFULLY RETURNS THE GAVEL TO
THE CHAIR. THANK YOU TO DOUBLE
DAVID BOWIE. AND WE WILL NOW
TAKE UP OF THE BILLS THAT WERE
LEFT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
YES I WILL START WITH THE
COMMITTEE ROLES. ET KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO HI THE VOTE IS ELEVEN
ZERO. COMMITTEE RULES ARE
PROVED. THAT'S ALL THAT TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI BERMAN. BERMAN HI
GABRIEL GABRIEL I IRWIN. IRWIN
HI KILEY KILEY I LOW. LOW I
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO HI THE VOTE
IS. TWELVE ZERO. CONSENT ITEMS-
PASSED. FILE ITEM ONE AB TWO
EIGHT EIGHT. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
HI BERMAN BERMAN HI KILEY.
KILEY I LOW. LOW I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO HI THE VOTE IS TWELVE
ZERO. ADAM IS OUT. ITEM TWO AB
THIRTY NINE. KILEY KILEY NO.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI. THE VOTE
IS EIGHT FOUR. BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM THREE AB TWO FOUR
FIVE MEDINA HI MEDINA I.
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I BERMAN
BERMAN I KILEY KILEY NO. SORRY
KILEY NOT VOTING. LOW LOW I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI. THE VOTE
IS ELEVEN ZERO BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM FOR AB TWO FIVE ONE
MEDINA HI MEDINA I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI BERMAN. BERMAN I
KILEY KILEY I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
HI VOTE IS TWELVE ZERO BILL IS
OUT. FILE ITEM FIVE AB FIVE
FOUR THREE MEDINA HI MEDINA I
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I BERMAN.
BERMAN HI KILEY. KILEY I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI THE VOTE
IS TWELVE ZERO LOSE OUT. FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB SIX THREE FIVE
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI NINE
CHOI I ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I
BERMAN BERMAN I KILEY KILEY I.
LEVINE LEVINE I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO HI THE VOTE IS TWELVE
ZERO BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM
NINE AB FIVE SEVEN SIX MEDINA
HI MEDINA HI CHOI HI CHOI I
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA HI BERMAN
BERMAN HI KILEY KILEY I. LEVINE
LEVINE HI SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI
THE VOTE IS TWELVE ZERO BILL IS
OUT. FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB TWO
SEVEN FIVE CHOI NINE CHOI I
BERMAN. BERMAN I HIGHLY HIGHLY
NARROW LEVINE LEVINE HI. THE
VOTE IS TEN ZERO BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB THREE
SEVEN FIVE CHOI NINE CHOI I
BERMAN BERMAN I KILEY. KILEY HI
LEVINE LEVINE HI THE VOTE IS.
TWELVE ZERO. BILL IS OUT FILE
ITEM. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR TO
ONE MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI HI
CHOI I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI
BERMAN. BERMAN HI KILEY KILEY
I. LEVINE LEVINE HI SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI THAT IS TWELVE ZERO
BILL IS OUT. AND THE STATE FILE
ITEM. FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE NINE
FIVE. BERMAN BERMAN HI THE VOTE
IS TWELVE ONE BILL IS OUT. I
THINK THAT'S IT. C. ON. TWO
SEVEN FIVE. YEAH EVERYTHING.
YEAH RATHER OKAY THANK YOU WE
ARE DURING. HELLO THREE OF US
WE MANAGED WE DID IT.